I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey, lady. Hey, lady. How are you? I'm good. I'm taking an Instagram video. What? They can't hear you, though, on my video. I can hear you on my headphones. I was doing all these little dance moves. Oh, I missed that. Right before we record, Sam plays a little bit of Creed song or music. And Jenna and I kind of just bop around and we kind of just
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重播播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。嘿，女士。嘿，女士。你好吗？我很好。我正在拍一个Instagram视频。什么？不过在我的视频里他们听不到你说话。我在耳机里能听到你说话。我刚才在跳各种小舞蹈。哦，我错过了。就在我们录音之前，萨姆放了一点克里德乐队的歌或音乐。然后珍娜和我就会跟着摇摆，我们基本上就是
helps us get into the episode. Every week we dance to Creed song. Love it. Well, what are we talking about this week, Angela? Oh, Jenna, I am so excited because we are talking about Phyllis' wedding. I love it so much. It's so good. This is season three, episode 15 written by Carolyn Williams and directed by Ken Whittingham. Summary. Do it. Phyllis and Bob Vance of Vance Refrigeration are getting married. Today is the day. Phyllis has asked Michael to push her father's wheelchair down the aisle. But after getting upstaged when Phyllis' dad decides to walk down the aisle, Michael tries to steal the show and is eventually bounced from the reception by Dwight. In the meantime, Pam is sad and upset by Jim and Karen's
这能帮我们进入状态。每周我们都会随着克里德的歌跳舞。太棒了。好了，安吉拉，我们这周要聊什么？哦，珍娜，我太兴奋了，因为我们要聊菲莉丝的婚礼。我太喜欢了。太棒了。这是第三季第15集，由卡洛琳·威廉姆斯编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆执导。剧情摘要。念吧。菲莉丝和范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯要结婚了。今天就是日子。菲莉丝请迈克尔推她父亲的轮椅走过过道。但是当菲莉丝的父亲决定自己走过过道而抢了风头后，迈克尔试图抢占焦点，最终被德怀特赶出了招待会。与此同时，帕姆对吉姆和卡伦的
relationship and the fact that Phyllis stole all of her wedding ideas and she leaves the reception with Roy. I forgot that Pam left with Roy. I forgot. Me too and I'm Pam. It's so good though. It's so good. But doesn't that happen? Like if you've been with someone a really long time and then you break up, you get back together a couple times before you really break up, right? That's real. Especially you're at a wedding and there's all these couples and the person you want to be with doesn't seem like they want to be with you. All of a sudden, the thing that you know is sitting right next to you. So you're like, well, okay, I feel like having some lovin'. Yeah, I guess so. All right.
关系以及菲莉丝偷走了她所有的婚礼创意感到难过和沮丧，她和罗伊一起离开了招待会。我忘了帕姆是和罗伊一起走的。我忘了。我也是，而且我就是帕姆。不过这真的很棒。太棒了。但难道不是这样吗？就像如果你和一个人在一起很长时间然后分手，在你真正分手之前，你们会复合好几次，对吧？这很真实。特别是当你身处婚礼现场，周围全都是情侣，而你想在一起的那个人似乎不想和你在一起。突然之间，你知道的那个人就坐在你身边。所以你会想，好吧，我觉得需要一点浪漫。对，我想是的。好吧。
Well, listen, fast fact number one. A lot of people wrote in Sovereign Hurley, Ellie Trevelyan, Winter Pulver, Leah Barbaro, Tia Minowski and many more want to know where was the wedding filmed. But then Colby Linderman, Dana Hill, Christina, Carolyn and Jennifer all wanted to know is it the same church where Jim and Pam had their wedding because they look very similar? It is not the same church. It's not the same church. But listen, before I tell you where Phyllis's wedding was filmed, we got even more mail about it, okay? Charis wrote in to say, at some point Phyllis and Pam both say they are Presbyterians. Was the wedding filmed at an actual Presbyterian church? I'm guessing the answer is yes, because the
听着，趣事一号。很多人来信，索维林·赫利、埃莉·特里维廉、温特·帕尔弗、莉亚·巴巴罗、蒂亚·米诺斯基等等，都想知道婚礼是在哪里拍摄的。但接着科比·林德曼、达娜·希尔、克里斯蒂娜、卡洛琳和詹妮弗都想知道这是否就是吉姆和帕姆举行婚礼的那座教堂，因为它们看起来非常相似。这不是同一座教堂。这不是同一座教堂。但是听着，在我告诉你菲莉丝的婚礼是在哪里拍摄之前，我们收到了更多关于它的信件，好吗？查丽斯来信说，在某个时候，菲莉丝和帕姆都说她们是长老会长。婚礼是在真正的长老会教堂拍摄的吗？我猜答案是肯定的，因为
crew pays a lot of attention to detail and Presbyterian churches love Maroon carpet. Chris Furr said, I am a pastor in the Christian church, Disciples of Christ, a small Protestant denomination, less than a million people, mostly in the US and Canada. In this episode, the Disciples logo is clearly visible around the 20 minute 32 second mark as Phyllis and Bob are cutting their wedding cake. I was curious about the choice to leave that specific banner in the background from a prop point of view. It's lighted and it's pretty distinctive. So he goes on to say, the funny thing about it is that theologically this would be a perfect compromise choice for a Lutheran and a Unitarian who like to keep things quote unquote spicy.
剧组非常注重细节，而且长老会教堂非常喜欢栗红色的地毯。克里斯·弗尔说：我是基督教会（基督门徒会）的一名牧师，这是一个小型新教教派，信徒不到一百万，主要分布在美国和加拿大。在这集里，当菲莉丝和鲍勃在切结婚蛋糕时，大约在20分32秒处，门徒会的标志清晰可见。从道具的角度来看，我对他们选择在背景中留下那个特定的横幅感到好奇。它有灯光照射，而且非常独特。所以他接着说，有趣的是，从神学角度来看，对于一个喜欢让生活“充满情趣”的路德宗信徒和一个一神论者来说，这将是一个完美的折中选择。
Any background on this would be cool as it is a big hit with our little Disciples family. Yes, we filmed Phyllis's wedding at the first Christian church of North Hollywood, which is located in Studio City and they are a Disciples of Christ church. Yes. So when I first moved to LA, I was looking for somewhere to go for Easter services. And I was driving around and I drove past this church and it's such a beautiful church, you know, it's the red brick and it has a steep, it looks very much like that is what a church looks like. You know what I mean? Yeah. And I drove past it and they had a big sign about their Easter service. And I thought, Oh, well, I'll go there for Easter services. And I did. And it was
关于这个有什么背景故事会很有趣，因为它在我们的门徒会小家庭里大受欢迎。是的，我们在北好莱坞第一基督教堂拍摄了菲莉丝的婚礼，它位于工作室城，是一座基督门徒会教堂。是的。所以当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我在找地方去做复活节礼拜。我开车四处转，路过了这座教堂，它是一座如此美丽的教堂，你知道的，红砖砌成，有一个尖顶，看起来非常符合人们对教堂的印象。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我开车路过它，他们挂着一个关于复活节礼拜的大招牌。我想，哦，那我得去那里做复活节礼拜。我去了。而且
very nice. Well, I'll give you another little fun fact about this church. And what this is where Kent Subornac and his wife Shelly got married. Oh, come on. And guess what? They just celebrated their 30th wedding anniversary this past May. Oh, that's so great. That's so lovely. Congratulations, you guys. And then guys, the reception took place in their social hall, which was on the second floor. So we were able to film everything at this one church. Yes, they have a fellowship hall. And they had, you know, they had the rooms like where Phyllis gets ready. Yeah, you know, all of that was already at this church. Well, incidentally, years later, we filmed a school recital scene for my TV show splitting up
非常好。好吧，我再告诉你关于这座教堂的一个小趣事。这里就是肯·苏伯纳克和他的妻子雪莉结婚的地方。哦，别这样。你猜怎么着？今年5月他们刚刚庆祝了结婚30周年纪念日。哦，太棒了。太美妙了。恭喜你们，各位。然后呢，各位，招待会在他们的社交大厅举行，位于二楼。所以我们能够在这同一座教堂里拍摄所有场景。是的，他们有一个团契大厅。而且他们有，你知道的，他们有像菲莉丝准备的那种房间。是的，你知道，所有这些原本就都在这座教堂里。顺便说一句，多年后，我们为我的电视剧《分手的
together in that sort of hall. And our holding room for hair and makeup was that same room where Phyllis is getting ready before her wedding. And there's that famous scene with Michael. Yeah. And I was like texting everybody was like blowing up everyone's texts. I'm like, I'm in the room where the fart happened. Here's another little thing about that church. I filmed there one day by myself because it's where Philip went to daycare. Oh, well, are you ready for fast fact number two? I am. We reached out to Phyllis. It's Phyllis's wedding. I know. How could we not talk to Phyllis, you guys? We are so thrilled. So Phyllis is back in St. Louis. She moved back there semi permanently a couple of years ago, and
伴侣》在那种大厅里拍摄了一个学校汇演场景。我们做发型和化妆的候场室就是当年菲莉丝在婚礼前准备的同一个房间。还有迈克尔的那个著名场景。对。我当时就像在给每个人发短信，大家的手机都要炸了。我说，我就在那个放屁发生的房间里。关于那座教堂还有个小事。有一天我自己在那儿拍过戏，因为那是菲利普去日托中心的地方。好吧，你准备好听趣事二了吗？准备好了。我们联系了菲莉丝。这是菲莉丝的婚礼。我知道。我们怎么能不跟菲莉丝聊聊呢，各位？我们太激动了。所以菲莉丝现在在圣路易斯。几年前她半永久性地搬回了那里，
she sent in some audio clips. So the first thing we asked Phyllis was just what was it like to get this script and wear a wedding gown? Here's the fun thing. Jenna, Phyllis and I are the three cast members that had big weddings. And it's kind of like it is your wedding because it's all about you. It's kind of really fun. Yes. All right. So Sam, play her clip. Hi, ladies. It's Phyllis Smith. Our soon to be known as Phyllis Lapin Vance of Vance Refrigeration, at least after this episode, right? I was so thrilled when I saw the script. Let's be truthful. Every time we had a table read, we'd all get to the table, look at the script, and see how many lines we had. So I was really excited and taken
她发来了一些音频剪辑。所以我们问菲莉丝的第一件事就是，拿到这个剧本并穿上婚纱是什么感觉？有趣的是，珍娜，菲莉丝和我都是剧组里举办过盛大婚礼的三位演员。这就好像是你的婚礼一样，因为一切都围绕着你展开。这真的很有趣。是的。好了，萨姆，播放她的剪辑。嗨，女士们。我是菲莉丝·史密斯。也就是即将被称为范斯冷气公司的菲莉丝·拉平·范斯，至少在这集之后是这样，对吧？当我看到剧本时，我太兴奋了。说实话，每次我们进行剧本围读时，大家都会来到桌旁，看着剧本，看看自己有多少台词。所以当我看到自己要嫁给我生命中的挚爱时，我真的既兴奋又惊讶。整集内容我都非常喜欢。你们问我的裙子。好吧，在那个年代，听起来像是黑暗时代，但那是2000年初。大码女性没有太多选择。我们看起来要么像祖母、曾祖母，要么像新娘。为丰满新娘准备的选择并不多。所以我很高兴我能有一件看起来漂亮而且相当舒服的裙子。我必须感谢服装组。他们真的非常非常照顾我。每次我需要去洗手间什么的，他们都马上赶来帮我处理一切。但是是的，在
back when I saw that I was getting married to my love of my life. The whole episode, I really enjoyed it all. You ask about my dresses. Well, back in those days, it sounds like the Dark Ages, but it was early 2000. Plus size women didn't have a lot of choices. We either looked like the grandmother or the great grandmother or the bride. There were not a lot of choices to be made for heavy set brides. And so I was just glad that I had a dress that looked pretty and was pretty comfortable. I have to give a shout out to wardrobe. They really, really took care of me. Every time I had to go to the restroom or anything, they were right there to help me out with everything. But yeah, back in
那个年代，我没有太多选择。所以我只是想确保我的手臂被遮住。我对自己的手臂在镜头前和公开场合露出来有点介意。至于裙子，是的，我很满意。它相当舒适。而且就像我说的，服装组真的照顾得我无微不至。他们每一秒钟都在旁边。啊，我觉得她在这一集里看起来美极了。她看起来太漂亮了。这是我这段时间以来第一次听到菲莉丝的声音。而且珍娜，当她把音频发过来，我第一次听的时候，真的让我感动得流泪。是的。
those days, I didn't have a lot of choices. And so I just wanted to make sure that my arms were covered. I have a thing about my arms showing on camera and in public. As far as the dress was concerned, yeah, I was happy with it. It was fairly comfortable. And like I said, wardrobe really kept me. They were right there every second of the moment. Aw, I thought she looked gorgeous in this episode. She looked so beautiful. That is the first time I've heard Phyllis's voice in a while. And Jenna, it just, it really made me tear up when I listened to it the first time when she sent them over. Yeah.
她就是，你能听出菲莉丝非常纯真。她就是一个纯洁的灵魂。你知道我的意思吗？你从她说话的语气就能听出来。你知道那段音频里我最喜欢的片段之一是什么吗？是她称自己为范斯冷气公司的菲莉丝·拉平·范斯。我知道。她在最后加上了这一句。我知道。我太喜欢了。听到菲莉丝的声音太有趣了。她发了好几段音频过来，各位。
She just, you can just hear Phyllis is just pure. She's just a pure soul. You know what I mean? And you just hear it when she talks. Do you know what one of my favorite parts of that audio clip was, and was that she referred to herself as Phyllis Lap and Vance of Vance Refrigeration? I know. She added it to the end. I know. I love it. Well that was so fun to hear Phyllis. And she sent in several audio clips, you guys.
所以在这集节目中我们都会听到她的声音。哦，她发了一些很棒的内容。所以第三个小贴士是，本集的导演肯·惠廷汉姆接受了我们的采访。肯执导了《办公室》的许多集，我们都非常喜欢他。演员们都很喜欢肯。萨姆，播放他的采访。肯·惠廷汉姆，非常感谢你能抽空前来。嗨，肯。
So we're going to hear from her throughout this episode. Oh, and she sent in some good stuff. Yeah. So tip number three is Ken Whittingham, the director of this episode, joined us for an interview. Ken directed several episodes of The Office, and we just loved him. The cast loved Ken. And Sam, play his interview. Ken Whittingham, thank you so much for stopping by. Hi, Ken.
嘿，嘿，谢谢你们邀请我。很高兴见到你们。真是太美妙了。我想起我们在剧组度过的所有美好时光，我已经好久没见你们了，看到你们的脸真是太神奇、太神奇了。我们看起来一模一样，对吧，肯？完全一样。也许稍微，嗯，也许稍微年轻了一点，我这么说吧。哦，好吧。
Hey, hey, thank you for having me. It is so nice to see you. Just so lovely. I think about all the great times we had on the show, and I haven't seen you guys in so long, and it's so, so amazing to see your faces. We look just the same, right, Ken? Exactly the same. Maybe a little, well, maybe a little younger, I'll say. Oh, okay.
我也是这么想的，是的。肯，我们总是喜欢先问问我们的嘉宾关于他们是如何得到《办公室》的工作的。你能告诉我们你是怎么认识格雷格的，以及你是怎么加入这部剧的吗？当然。我接到经纪人的电话，他说他们要在美国重拍《办公室》。全国广播公司（NBC）要制作《办公室》。我已经是英国版的超级粉丝了。我说，当然，我去面试。
That's what I would have said as well, yes. Well Ken, we always like to start by asking our guests a little bit about how they got their job on The Office. Can you tell us how you met Greg and how you came to be a part of the show? Sure. I got a call from my agent, and he said they're going to redo The Office in America. NBC is going to do The Office. And I was already a big fan of the British version. I said, sure, I go for the interview.
于是他们给我寄了DVD，其实我当时对它没抱太大希望。我说，哦天哪，我希望他们不要搞砸了，因为这是一部如此精彩的剧。我看了之后，心想，哇，这真的很不错。所以我去面试了，见到了特里·温伯格和格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我们进行了交谈。我们讨论了美国是否已经准备好迎接这种类型的剧，我们进行了广泛的探讨，你知道的，讨论美国人能不能接受它。
And so they sent me, they actually sent me the DVD, and I didn't have a lot of hope for it. I said, oh man, I hope they don't miss this stuff because it was such a brilliant show. And I watched it, and I was like, wow, this is really good. So I went in for the interview, and I met with Terry Weinberg and Greg Daniels, and we talked about it. And we talked about if America was ready for this type of show, and we really talked extensively about it, you know, if America was going to get it.
我非常乐观地表示，我认为美国已经准备好迎接一些不同寻常、耳目一新的东西了。这就是我们的相遇。我想那正是在新一季开始之前，是的。所以他们已经拍完了试播集，然后他们正在为主演寻找导演。没错。哇。我完全可以想象格雷格听到这种对话时的兴奋神情，你知道的，就像谈论这部剧以及它将如何轰动美国，美国观众会作何反应。诸如此类的话题他总是非常开放，你知道吗？
And I was very optimistic in saying that I think America's ready for something different, something new. And that's how we met. I guess it was right before the season started, yeah. So they had done the pilot, and then they were looking for directors for the series. Correct. Wow. I can definitely see Greg eating up that conversation, you know, sort of like talking about the show and how it's going to hit America, and how America's going to react to it. That's all sort of like, he's so open to those kind of conversations, you know?
对，我们谈了很久。基本上我们聊的都是这个，因为我提到了另一部在美国反响不太好的剧。我想它叫《绝对芬芳》。哦，是的。他们在美国尝试过，很有趣，因为我顺着这个方向聊下去，其实我并不想聊这个。我说，对，就像那部剧《绝对芬芳》一样。他们说，哦，在你多说之前，那部剧也是我们做的。我们制作了那部剧。
Yeah, we talked a long time about it. That's basically all we talked about, because I referenced another show that really didn't work that well in America. I think it was called Absolutely Fabulous. Oh, yeah. They tried it in America, and it was funny, because I was going down this row, but I really didn't want to go. I said, yeah, just like the show, Absolutely Fabulous. They said, oh, before you say too much, we did that show also. We produced this show.
哦。是杰瑞·温伯格。所以他们说，那你喜欢那部剧的什么？我说，嗯，我说，我觉得每个人，这确实是事实，我觉得每个人看起来都太漂亮了。每个人都长得太好看了，感觉一点也不真实，你知道吗？嗯。肯，你执导了《办公室》的很多集，其中有两集是外景。你有在溜冰场拍摄的迈克尔的生日，现在还有菲莉丝的婚礼。让我们去旅行并在外景地拍摄，感觉怎么样？
Oh. It was Jerry Weinberg. So they said, well, what did you like about that show? I said, well, I said, I think everybody, which was true, I think everybody looked too pretty. Everybody was just really good looking, and it just didn't feel real, you know? Mm-hmm. Ken, you directed a lot of episodes on The Office, and two were on location. You had Michael's birthday that was at the ice skating rink, and now Phyllis' wedding. What was it like having us travel and be on location?
太棒了。在户外感觉太棒了，因为有时候《办公室》会显得有点幽闭恐惧，而且非常安全。转移到户外去外景拍摄的挑战在于，依然要拍出斯克兰顿的感觉，或者工作室城以外某个地方的感觉。是的。所以我们不想看到棕榈树。这真的是一个巨大的挑战。所以在前期筹备期间，我们做了大量准备工作，以确保它看起来有点像斯克兰顿或其他地方，一个平淡无奇的地方。所以这很有趣。能够身处新的空间，尝试不同的事情，并把这部剧稍微打开一点，这真的很有趣。我一直很喜欢我制作的任何节目，
It was great. It was great being outside, because sometimes The Office can get a little claustrophobic, and it's very safe. The challenge to moving outside and going on location is still give it that feel of Scranton, or someplace other than Studio City. Yeah. So we didn't want to see palm trees. So that was a real challenge. And so during prep, we really prepped heavily to make sure that it looked somewhat like Scranton or somewhere else, someplace nondescript. So that was fun. And it was just fun to be in new spaces and try different things and kind of open the show up. I'm always a big fan of any show
走到户外，融入到外景世界中一点。我觉得人们没有意识到的是一集的筹备过程。你有多长时间来筹备一集？因为我们说过我们一周拍一集，但你在开拍前的筹备期有多长？我们的筹备期是，相信那一集只有四天。就这些。要把整部剧转移出去，时间可真不多。我的天。
that I do, going outside and getting into the world a little bit. I think something people don't realize is the prep process for an episode. How long would you get to prep an episode? Because we've said we shoot for a week, but how long was your prep before shooting? Our prep was, believe that show is four days. That's it. That's not a lot to move a whole show. No. Cow.
然后你们是不是要坐着一辆小货车到处转来查看外景地，就像一堆人挤在一辆货车里？是的。我对你们大包小包离开片场有着深刻的记忆，我们在想，他们去哪儿了？是的，通常是在第一天，因为他们会，外景部门会锁定几个，比如部门会锁定几个我们可以选择的备选地点。然后我会去那些地方，导演和制片人，我们会去那些
And then don't you like ride around in a little van and look at locations, like a bunch of you all crammed in a van? I do. I have such a memory of you guys loading up and leaving set, and we're like, where do they go? Yeah, it would really be the first day, because they would do, they would lock down a couple of, like the location of the department would lock down a couple of options that we would have. And then I would go to those options, the director and producers, we would go to those
外景地。可能会有两三个不同的地方。然后我们会在那时做出决定。一切都取决于它是否适合拍摄，你知道的，仅仅是背景以及对外景地的可及性。我们能搞定吗？我们能轻松地把摄影机搬进去再轻松地搬出来吗？嗯，有很多事情我们必须，我们必须注意或意识到。所以，基本上就是在那个筹备日。我们要做的第一件事就是出去努力锁定外景地，因为获得使用特定外景地的许可证需要几天时间。
locations. There might be two or three different places. And then we would make the decision then. And it was all about whether or not it was shootable, you know, just backgrounds and just accessibility to the location. Could we get it? Could we load cameras in easily and load out easily? Well, there are a lot of things we had to, we had to be aware of or be conscious of. So yeah, that would be basically on that prep date. That'd be the first thing we would do is go out and try to lock down the locations because it would take a few days to get a
那么，你更喜欢在办公室的主办公区内部拍摄，还是在外部拍摄？我其实没什么偏好。我真的没有偏好，因为，你知道的，剧本实在是太棒了。我的意思是，字面意思，我昨天还在读菲莉丝的婚礼，又读了一遍剧本。它就是那么，我不知道，剧本写得太好了。我的意思是，真的写得太好了。所以不管在哪里拍摄都无所谓，因为台词真的推动了喜剧效果，你知道吗？
permit to use specific locations. Now, did you have a preference of shooting the episodes inside the office bullpen or outside? I didn't really have a preference. I didn't really have a preference because, you know, the writing was just so good. I mean, literally, I was reading Phyllis's wedding yesterday, reading the script again. And it was just so, I don't know, it's just written so well. I mean, it's just written so well. So it was just like wherever it was, it didn't matter because the words really kind of drove the comedy, you know?
是的。所以，这就是它的魅力所在，你知道的？这一集里有所有这些精彩的小片段，你知道的，有帕姆和罗伊跳舞，然后有安吉拉和德怀特在室外，还有所有这些小插曲，比如迈克尔的头在窗户里上下晃动。弄清楚这些小片段应该在什么地方发生以及你是如何捕捉到它们的，那是一种什么样的体验？嗯，我会做的是，我有点，我是一个超级筹备控。所以我会，我会，我想对于这一集，我列了一个分镜头表，并按照我们
Yeah. So it was, that's what was great about it, you know? There were all of these great little moments in this episode, you know, you had the Pam and Roy dancing and then you had Angela and Dwight outside and then all these little vignettes like Michael's head bobbing up in the window. And what was that like to sort of figure out where those little moments would happen and how you captured them? Well, what I would do is I kind of, I'm a super prepper. So I would, I would, I kind of, I think for this episode, I've made a shot list and in the order in which we would
要进行的顺序排列。所以我会做的是，我有点像跳房子一样。我会在其他地方设置好一些东西，然后拿一台摄影机去拍别的东西。所以我总是稍微保持领先，以便能够捕捉到所有这些东西，因为那一集我们有，我几天前刚看过。我们在现场拍了很多最终没有剪进正片里的镜头，你知道的？所以，而且我认为通常情况下，每一集我们通常都会超长大约六、七、八分钟。所以我们拍的素材比我们真正需要的要多得多。但我总是保持领先，试着把所有东西都拍下来，你知道的，而且计划非常非常周密。有些事情，你知道，在拍摄当天我们会
go on and go in. So what I would do is I kind of hopscotch. I would set up something somewhere else and then take a camera and go shoot something else. And so I was always staying ahead a little bit to be able to capture all that stuff because that episode we had, I was just looking at it a few days ago. There were so many moments that weren't in the episode that we shot, you know? And so, and I think typically we would be about six, seven, eight minutes over typically on every episode. So we'd shoot more than a lot than we, more than we really needed. But I would just stay ahead and just try to get it all in, you know, and just, and it was very, very planned. And some things, you know, on the day we would, we
做一些没有计划的事情。就像阿尔叔叔走到外面去时，我想最初他应该是坐在一张长椅上的。然后我们到了外面。那是夜里。我说，如果他走到街上，他就会是绿色的。然后他逆着交通方向走去，汽车开过来，字面意思就是汽车在按喇叭什么的。所以我们把所有那些写出来的东西都用上了。不，那是按剧本演的。我们只是，你知道，当场想出来的，你知道的，所以这创造了更多的张力。是的。比他只是坐在长椅上要好。是的。真是个好主意。你真的很担心他会在夜里随便走到什么地方去。没错。完全正确。
would do things that weren't planned. Like when Uncle Al went outside, I think initially he was supposed to be sitting on a bench. And, and we got outside. It was nighttime. And I said, if he walked into the street, he was green. And then he went the opposite way against traffic and cars came down and literally cars were honking and everything. So we used all that stuff is written. So no, that was scripted. We just kind of came up with that, you know, off the, off the top of our heads, you know, so that created so much more tension. Yes. Then him just sitting on a bench. Yes. Such a good idea. You were really worried he was just going to be wandering off somewhere in the night. Right. Exactly.
是的。我想那时你永远不会看到灯光变绿。是的。所以我们计算好了时间和一切。所以，这真的非常有趣。我很高兴它最终被剪进正片里。是的。肯，我看到安吉拉·马丁到达并看到德怀特、他们进行了简短交流的那一刻时，真的觉得太逗了，但，那差不多就是那样。然后，然后我们就得走进教堂。我记得你当时跟我探讨过我们该如何，如果你说，向左突围，不要逗留。我只记得你让我们稍微发挥了一下。那太荒谬、太滑稽了。我们玩得太开心了。那很有趣。那真的很有趣，因为我只是，我真的想在你们两人之间制造那种尴尬感，你知道的，因为我知道你们后来本该去见丹尼斯。
Yeah. I think then never saw you see the light turn. Yeah. So we timed it and everything. So it was, that was really a lot of fun. I'm glad that made it into the cut. Yeah. Well, Ken, I got so tickled just watching that moment when Angela Martin arrives and sees Dwight and they have that brief exchange, but that, that was kind of it. And then, then we had to go into the church. And I remember playing with you about how do we then like, if you're like, break left, don't linger. And I just remember you letting us play a little bit with that. And it was so absurd and ridiculous. We just had so much fun. That was fun. That was a lot of fun because I just, I really wanted to create the awkwardness between the
是的。然后所以必须有这种小小的，你知道的，这种张力，尤其是当他夸奖你的时候，你知道的，所以我觉得那样的情节，你知道，我不知道，在我的脑海里，那差不多就敲定了。就像你对他的吸引力更大了。所以你就能更容易地把另一个对她来说如此完美的家伙给打发掉。是的。这就是为什么你们的戏份没有进正片的原因。菲莉丝把安吉拉安排在这个名叫丹尼斯的
two of you, you know, because I knew that you were supposed to be meeting Dennis later on. Yes. And then so they had to be this little, you know, this tension, especially when he gave you that compliment, you know, and so I think that kind of, you know, I, I don't know, in my mind, that kind of sealed it. Like you just became more attractive to him. And so it was easier for you to, to kind of blow this other guy off who was so perfect for her. Yeah. That's why you guys didn't make it in the episode. Phyllis sits Angela next to this
家伙旁边。她试图在招待会上撮合他们，你知道的。而且丹尼斯是个兽医。他喜欢猫和耶稣。我的意思是，她，她选择了德怀特，因为他告诉她，她看起来像英国女王。太搞笑了。我知道。所以，是的，我希望，我希望关于丹尼斯的有些内容能剪进正片，但我想我们，再次强调，我们只是没有时间。但这里面有太多精彩的内容了，你知道的，是的。是的。我们甚至还有，我想是的，我觉得它也没有剪进正片里。我们有
guy named Dennis. She kind of tries to set her up at the, you know, at the reception. And Dennis is a vet. He loves cats and Jesus. I mean, she, she chooses Dwight cause he told her, she looks like the queen of England. So funny. I know. So yeah, I wish, I wish some of the stuff would have made it in other stuff from Dennis, but I guess we, you know, again, we just didn't have time. But there's so much good stuff in here, you know, Yeah. Yeah. And we even had, I think it was, I don't think it made it into the episode as well. We had
迈克走过去，有一个椅子，你知道的，那种人们不能走楼梯时用的椅子。是的。它上下移动着。我们也没有用到任何这些。实在是太多了。这就是身处外景地的美妙之处，你拥有这些空间，并且你会冒出这些点子，你可以做一些完全没有剧本的即兴表演。你知道的，所以，那，那是外景拍摄的伟大之处之一。
Mike going, there was a chair that kind of, you know, those chairs where people can't walk upstairs. Yes. That was going up and down. We didn't use any of that either. We were just, it was just so much. And that's the beauty about being on location is that you have these spaces that, and you get these ideas that you can just do stuff that's not scripted at all. You know, so that's, that's, that's one of the great things about being on location.
好吧，有很多非常棒的被删减片段。所以对于拥有DVD的观众来说，你们必须去看肯拍摄的所有其他内容。人们总是想知道剧集的导演是否也必须拍摄闪回时刻。你必须拍摄小迈克在他妈妈与杰夫的婚礼上的那个时刻吗？是的。是的。那太有趣了。那真的很有趣，因为我们，我们知道它需要看起来有点复古，并且，所以，我们移动摄影机的方式就像使用旧的VHS摄像机一样，你知道的，然后我们，当然，在，在后期制作中我们进行了，
Well there are a lot of really great deleted scenes. So for people that have the DVDs, you have to go see all the other stuff that Ken shot. People always want to know if the directors of episodes also have to shoot the flashback moments. Did you have to shoot that moment with little Michael at his mom's wedding to Jeff? Yeah. Yeah. That was a lot of fun. That was a lot of fun because we, we knew that it needed to look a little vintage and, and, and so, and we kind of moved the camera like was old VHS camera, you know, and, and then we, you know, of course in, in post we kind
修饰，但是，但这真的很有趣。我们拍摄了它，并希望它看起来棒极了，看起来有复古感，你知道的，看起来更老旧一些。所以我想，我想我们做到了。看起来棒极了。你们是在第一天就把它拍好，以便迈克后来可以看，还是说你们用CGI把它合成到电视上？是的，我们做到了。我们在第一天就拍了它，然后我们，我们回放了它。我相信我们当时就是这么做的。
of doctored it, but, but it was really fun. It was, it was a lot of fun that we, and we, we shot it and we just hope that it would look great and look, look vintage, you know, look older. So I think, I think we achieved it. It looked fantastic. Do you do that on the first day so that then Michael can watch it later or do you like CGI it onto the TV? Yes, we did. We shot it on the first day and then we, we played it back. I believe that's how we did it.
好吧，这一集里有太多精彩的大型场景设置了。有没有哪个时刻是拍摄起来最具挑战性的，或者对你来说非常有趣？仅仅是，这些击中你的场景之一。我并不，我不认为有什么特别具挑战性的事情。有一，有一个场景真的很难拍过去。我要说那确实挺具挑战性的，因为我们当时根本停不下来笑。那就是，当迈克走进房间去查看菲莉丝的情况看她准备得怎么样了，然后他说，你知道的，那两个，呃，排气或释放气体，对，对，对。而且，你知道有趣的地方在于，
Well, there were so many just fantastic big setups for this episode. Was there any moment that was the most challenging to shoot or like something really funny for you? Just, just one of these scenes that, that just hit you. I don't, I don't think that there was really anything too challenging. One, one, there was one scene that was really hard to get through. And I would say that was kind of challenging because we were just, we could not stop laughing. And that's when, when Michael went into the check on our Phyllis to see how she was doing, and then he said, you know, the two, the two, uh, pass gas or break wind, yeah, yeah, yeah. And, and you know, the funny
那是一个加进剧本里的笑话，本来并不是真的打算留在剧本里的，真的，那从来都不是真的打算保留的，它就像是一个笑话，如果发生这种事会很好笑。然后它就留下来了。然后它，然后它花了一点时间，我想卡洛琳，卡洛琳在告诉我那是卡洛琳·威廉姆斯，本集的编剧。嗯，所以它就留下来了，我们就把它拍了。而迈克，你知道的，史蒂夫太棒了。他根本停不下来笑。而且他停不下来。我从来没见过他那样笑场。我们所有人都笑得前仰后合，我们花了大约一个小时才拍完。因为我们根本停不下来笑。
thing about that is, um, that was a joke that was put into the script that wasn't really supposed to stay in the script that really, yeah, that was never really supposed to, it was just like a joke that wouldn't be funny if this happened. And then it just lived. And then it, and then it took, I guess Carol, and Carolyn was telling me that's Carolyn Williams, the writer of the episode. Um, so it just kind of stayed and we just shot it. And Michael, you know, Steve was so good. He could not stop laughing. And, and he could not stop. And I've never seen him break like that. And we all were just like, it took us about an hour to get there. Cause we could not stop laughing.
你知道，菲莉丝总是能表现出那种真诚的表情，你知道的，每当你不得不对她刻薄或者对她说一些随意的台词时，她就会用那种甜美的眼神看着你。所以我能理解史蒂夫为什么拍不下去。就像是，那味道真的很刺鼻。而她只是，对吧。然后他开始弄乱她的头发。哦，天哪。她只是说，好吧，你得，你得走了。我觉得她内心的独白就是：六周假期，六周假期。没错。因为那是她将要得到的。完全正确。这就是她熬过去的方式。
Well, you know, Phyllis always was able to have such this earnest expression, you know, and whenever you had to be mean to her or just like have some random line towards her and she would look at you with these sweet eyes. So I can, I can see Steve not being able to get through it. Being like, that is really pungent. She's just like, right. And then he started messing around with her hair. Oh my God. She's just like, okay, you got to, you got to go. I feel like her whole interior monologue was just six weeks vacation, six weeks vacation. Right. Because that's what she was going to get. Exactly. That's how she's going to get through it.
是的。和鲍勃·范斯一起。对，完全正确。我喜欢，我非常喜欢在婚礼上，他们说：菲莉丝，你是否愿意嫁给范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯？你把整家公司都嫁了。这才是最棒的地方。我想那是在公司合并时，她告诉，她告诉拉什达，你知道的，你根本不知道鲍勃·范斯是谁。小妞，你还有得学呢。这就是它滑稽的地方，因为鲍勃·范斯在那个小镇上是个大人物。是的。所以他总是，你知道的，一切都围绕着范斯冷气公司。每个人都认识他。好吧，菲莉丝现在是范斯冷气公司的第一夫人。我的意思是，她要扮演好这个角色。对。没错。我敢打赌她得去，我不知道。范斯冷气公司有什么剪彩活动吗，
Yeah. With Bob Bantz. Yeah, exactly. And I loved, I loved in the wedding. I loved so much that they were like, do you Phyllis take Bob Bantz a fans refrigeration? You're taking the whole thing. That's what was so great about it. I think it was in the merger when she told, when she told Rashida, you know, you don't know who Bob Bantz is. You got a lot to learn, Missy. And that's what was so funny about it because Bob Bantz is a big deal in that town. Yeah. So he was all, you know, it's all about Bob Bantz refrigeration. Everybody knew him. Well, Phyllis is now the first lady of Vance refrigeration. I mean, she's going to play the part. Right. Right. I'm sure she's going to have to go to, I don't know. Is there ribbon cuttings
当他们在一间新餐厅或什么地方安装了所有设备的时候？对。我觉得会有一个购物中心，那里有像好莱坞星光大道那样的小星星，而鲍勃·范斯就有一颗。他们全都去了斯克兰顿市中心。没错。然后还得拍个广告，她必须出现在范斯冷气公司的广告里。哦，真希望我们当时拍了那个。肯，这太绝了。完全正确。哦，这就是我们错失的内容。肯，我们之前说过你执导了九集《办公室》。你最喜欢哪一集吗？你能挑出一集最喜欢的吗？这很难。你知道吗？这很难分高下。我觉得在菲莉丝的婚礼和医疗保健之间，其实。哦，是的。热狗手指。对。是的。医疗保健。哦，
involved in Vance refrigeration when they install like everything in a new restaurant or something? Yeah. I feel like there's a shopping mall where there's little like kind of stars like the Hollywood Walk of Fame and Bob Bantz gets one. They all go to downtown Scranton. That's right. And then there has to be a commercial and she has to be in the commercial for Bob Bantz. Oh, I wish we never shoot that. Ken, that is brilliant. Exactly. Oh, that's the content we're missing. Ken, so we said before that you've directed nine episodes of The Office. Do you have a favorite? Can you pick a favorite? That's hard. You know what? It's a toss-up. I think between Phyllis's wedding, actually, and health care. Oh, yeah. Hot dog fingers. Yeah. Yeah. Health care. Oh,
天哪。我可以一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地看。我的意思是，最棒的是，我们只是，我想我们拍过，我们绝对是在前六集里拍的，但我们当时都在试图弄清楚这部剧到底是关于什么的，并试图把它拍成我们自己的风格，尝试不同的东西。而且我们都还在适应彼此。这太棒了。我喜欢做，你知道的，参与它的初期制作，因为那是，那是我们拍的第三集吗？你还记得吗？你知道，我觉得那一季我们拍得有点乱序。所以它可能是，我们拍的第五集，但它是播出的第三集。播出的那一集。就是这样。对。那是早期。那是我们只拍了六集然后就被打发回家的时候。对，完全正确。那是一段非常
my God. I can watch that over and over and over. I mean, and it was so great about it. We were just, I think we shot, we definitely shot it within the first six, but we were all trying to figure out what the show was about and trying to make it our own and trying different stuff. And we were all getting used to each other. It was just great. I loved doing the, you know, being in the beginning of it because it was, was that the third episode we shot? Do you remember? You know, I think we shot that season a little out of order. So it might have been like, it was the fifth episode we shot, but it was the third episode that aired. It aired. That's what it was. Yeah. Those were the early days. That was when we only got six and then they sent us home. Yeah, exactly. That was a really
神奇的时光。真的是，真的是。每个人对此都感到很不确定。我只记得离开时感觉好极了。你知道的，就觉得，哇，那真的很有趣、很新鲜、很棒。而且演员阵容，每个人都完美极了。我记得我的经纪人说，到了下一季的时候，我看到了它从iTunes上获得的所有关注度。所以，所以我特地打电话给经纪人说，听着，你得让我回那个剧组，你知道的，那部剧，你知道的，因为当时我觉得前途未卜。我们不知道我们是否还能回归。对。我说，如果他们回归，我必须加入，我想参与那部剧。所以，幸运的是，大学生们让我们，你知道的，名声大噪。
magical time. It really, really was. And everybody was so unsure about it. And I just remember walking away and just feeling so good about it. You know, just feeling so like, wow, that was really fun and different and great. And the cast was, it was, everybody was perfect. And I remember my agent saying, the next season came around and I saw the, all the, the attention that it was getting from, from, from iTunes. And, and so I, so I made sure I called my agent and said, look, you got to get me back on that show, you know, that show is, you know, because I think it was up in the air. We didn't know if we were coming back or not. Yeah. I said, if they come back, I got to be, I want to be involved in that show. So, so luckily the college kids got us, you know, got to put on the map.
对，大学生们，现在还有初中生们。完全正确。他们让我们一直延续下去。你知道有趣的是，我依然，我真的会把这个挂在嘴边，当人们问我拍过什么剧，如果我跟某人解释说我是个导演，他们说，好吧，有什么节目是我知道的吗？我说，嗯，有一个节目叫《办公室》。我对此感到很骄傲。他们会说，什么？所以我因此得到了很多认可。我非常感谢能成为那部剧的一部分。这真的是一部非常非常棒的剧。而且它是那种你可以一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地观看，却依然能发现乐趣的剧，因为有所有这些微妙之处和，以及各种精彩时刻，就像我们刚才聊到的迈克尔在，你知道的，在窗户里上下跳跃，看起来就像，你知道的，帕姆和罗伊在跳舞，然后，你知道的，帕姆和罗伊，然后，然后，你知道的，德怀特，你和德怀特，你知道的，这真的都是很甜蜜、很温馨的时刻，你只需要，你知道的，去珍惜那些美好的时刻。肯，这真的太美妙了。非常感谢你。那么，你现在在忙些什么？我现在很好，我知道你执导了一些《祝福混乱》，那是替代我的节目的那部剧。不过，如果能让你感觉好受点的话，我们的剧也被取消了。所以我的意思是，我并不是说我感觉好受点了。但，是的，我在Netflix上和杰米·福克斯合作制作一部新剧。它叫《停下让我尴尬》。大致是根据他和女儿的
Yeah. The college kids and now the middle schoolers. Exactly. They're keeping us going. You know, it's funny is that, that I still, I really lead with that, which when people ask me what shows, if I explain to somebody that I'm a director and they say, well, shows, have you done anything I've known? I goes, well, we'll show call the office. You know, I bragged about it. They're like, what? So I get a lot of props for that. I'm just so appreciative to be a part of that show. It's just such, just such a great show. And it's the kind of show that you can just still watch over and over and over and still, because there's all these little subtleties and, and just moments, you know, like we talked about Michael jumping up and down in the, you know, in the,
关系改编的。然后，然后到了秋天，现在是深秋，我想在选举之后，我正在为NBC制作一部由肯an·汤普森主演的剧。它叫《伴肯南醒来》。主演是肯安·汤普森、唐·约翰逊和玛娅·鲁道夫。玛娅·鲁道夫饰演他的妻子。但她去世了。所以我想，这基本上就是剧情梗概：他主持一档晨间节目，然后抚养两个孩子，唐·约翰逊是他的岳父。哦，天哪。对，所以，所以这听起来会非常有趣。我真的很期待。好吧，肯，你深受《办公室》演员们的喜爱。我们，我们采访了剧组的很多演员，在做这个播客的过程中，我们联系了大家，菲莉丝给我们发来了音频剪辑，她当时就说，哦，还有肯·惠廷
you know, the window and it looks like when, you know, when Pam and Roy were dancing and, and then, you know, Pam and Roy and then, and then, you know, Dwight, you and Dwight, you know, it was just, it was just really sweet, sweet moments. And you just, you know, just cherish those, those great moments. Ken, this was so lovely. Thank you so much. And what, what are you up to now? I'm well now, I know that you directed some bless your mess, which is the show that replaced my show that was. But just, but if it makes you feel better, we got canceled too. So I mean, I'm not saying I feel better. But yeah, I'm just, I'm doing a new show with Jamie Foxx on firm Netflix. It's called death stop embarrassing me. It's loosely based on him and his daughter's
汉姆。我们总是很高兴肯能在现场。只要知道我们的演员对你充满了爱，珍娜和我都希望你能再次回归。所以，随时欢迎回来。随时都可以。我很乐意。随时。我爱你们，我也想念你们。我甚至还会想起你，珍娜，我会想，当我在拉古纳时，我会说，珍娜搬到这儿来了吗？我不知道她是不是在附近。好吧，我们以前花过多少时间只谈论拉古纳、搬到拉古纳、看拉古纳的房子。我有一个梦想，就是有一天搬到海滨别墅，从洛杉矶套现。对。是的。你在极力称赞拉古纳。你知道，这真的很有趣，因为在我挂断电话后，当我做完这些之后，我就要下去了，我太太现在就在那儿。所以，我一会儿就在那儿。
relationship. And then, and then in the fall, late fall now, I think after the election, I'm doing a show for NBC with Kenan Thompson. It's called wake up with Kenan. And it's Kenan Thompson and Don Johnson and Maya Rudolph. Maya Rudolph was his wife. But it passed away. So I think, so that's basically the storyline is he has his, he has a morning show and then he's taken care of two kids and Don Johnson is his father-in-law. Oh my gosh. Yeah. So, so that's, it seems like it's going to be a lot of fun. I'm really looking forward to that. Well, Ken, you were so beloved by the office cast. We, we have talked to so many of the cast members and doing this podcast, we reach out to people, Phyllis sent us an audio clips and she was like, oh, and it was Ken Whitting
哦，天哪。好吧，向你送去我们所有的爱。谢谢你今天能来。谢谢你，肯。谢谢，妈妈。再见。再见。多有趣啊！他太棒了。好吧，让我们开始讨论这一集吧，珍娜。我们从一个冷开场开始。这是一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。你知道，吉姆说他必须重启电脑，然后它发出了这种叮咚声。接着他给德怀特递了一颗薄荷糖。然后他一遍又一遍地这样做，有点像对德怀特进行巴甫洛夫式的，你知道的那种实验。是的。而且吉姆的恶作剧成功了。是的。重复这样做几次后，叮咚声响起，德怀特立刻把手伸出来要糖。而且他不知道为什么。是的。他只是处于条件反射。是的。
Hamlin. We always loved it when Ken was there. And just know that you have so much love for you from our cast and Jenna and I would love for you to come back. So, so yeah, come on back. Anytime. I would love it. Anytime. I love you guys and I miss you guys. And I even still think about you, Jenna, I go, when I'm in Laguna, I go, did Jenna move down here? I wonder if she around here. Well, we would spend how much time just talking about Laguna, moving to Laguna, looking at the house of Laguna. I have this dream of like one day moving to a beach house, cashing out of LA. Right. Yeah. You are talking up Laguna. You know, it's really funny because right after I get off when, when I'm done with this, I'm going down there, my wife's down there now. So, I'll be there.
所以，我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。布雷基、艾玛、凯拉、贝瑟尼和埃莉都来信说，在这一集的冷开场中，这个场景是多日镜头的蒙太奇。约翰和雷恩为了这一个场景不得不经常换衣服吗？是的。他们有一个挂满各种不同换装服装的衣架，他们会拍完去换衣服，再拍完去换衣服，拍完再换衣服。对。而且与此同时，服装组在做记录，片场还有瓦达。她就像是在记录他们什么时候穿着什么服装，以便他们能完成拍摄。但是各位，不仅仅是约翰和雷恩。我们其余所有人都在背景里。是的。任何被摄像机拍到的人也都必须换衣服。好吧，我记得去上班拍摄这个冷开场时。而且有类似
Oh, man. Well, all of our love to you. Thanks for coming on today. Thanks, Ken. Thanks, my mom. Bye. Bye. How fun was that? He's the best. Well, let's get into this episode, Jenna. We start with a cold open. It's a classic Jim prank. You know, Jim says he has to reboot his computer and it makes this chiming noise. And then he offers Dwight an Altoid. And then he keeps doing this over and over, sort of like that Pavlovian, you know, sort of experiment with Dwight. Yes. And Jim's prank works. Yeah. After several times of doing this, the ding goes off and Dwight immediately puts his hand out for a mint. And he doesn't know why. Yeah. He's just doing it on reflex. Yes.
天哪。好吧，我们向你致以所有的爱。谢谢你今天来到这里。谢谢你，肯。谢谢我的妈妈。再见。再见。这太有趣了吧？他是最棒的。好吧，我们进入这一集吧，珍娜。我们从冷开场开始。这是一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。你知道，吉姆说他必须重启电脑，然后发出这种叮当声。然后他给德怀特一块奥托伊特薄荷糖。接着他一遍又一本地这样做，有点像对德怀特的巴甫洛夫式的实验。是的。吉姆的恶作剧成功了。是的。在重复这样做多次后，叮咚声响起，德怀特立刻伸手去要薄荷糖。他自己也不知道为什么。是的。他完全是处于条件反射。是的。
So, we got a lot of mail about this. Blakey, Emma, Kayla, Bethany and Elise all wrote in to say, in the cold open of this episode, the scene is a montage of multiple days. Did John and Rain have to constantly change outfits just to get this one scene? Yes. They had a rack of clothes of all these different changes and they would film go change, film go change, film go change. Yeah. Yeah. And all the while wardrobe is keeping track and Vada on set. She's like keeping track of when they're in what outfit and so that they could just get it done. But guys, it wasn't just John and Rain. All the rest of us were in the background. Yes. Anyone that the camera saw had to change as well. Well, I remember getting to work to shoot this cold open. And there were like
所以，我们收到了很多关于这方面的邮件。布莱基、艾玛、凯拉、贝瑟尼和埃莉斯都写信来说，在本集的冷开场中，这个场景是多天画面的剪辑。约翰和雷恩为了拍好这一个场景，是不是不得不经常换衣服？是的。他们有一个挂满各种不同换洗衣物的衣架，他们拍完去换衣服，再拍完去换衣服，拍完再去换衣服。是的，是的。而且在此期间，服装部门一直在做记录，现场的瓦达也是。她一直在记录他们什么时候穿什么衣服，这样他们就能顺利完成拍摄。但是各位，不仅仅是约翰和雷恩。我们其余的人都在背景里。是的。镜头拍到的任何人也都必须换衣服。嗯，我记得去上班拍摄这个冷开场时。有大概
seven outfits in my trailer, which never happened. We would have one outfit we would wear it every single day for five days. I mean, they washed it guys. They washed it. You know, but yeah, we wore the same thing every day. Yeah. But to walk in and like my little closet was totally full of all these clothes. I had to go back and look and be like, wait, what? Oh, yeah, it's the cold open with the dinging computer. That's a great catch. And then we just had this funded bit from Amanda Teague who said, my psychology professor use the cold open of this episode to teach us about the Pavlovian theory. Oh my gosh. Well, last night I read up a lot about Pavlov. I'm not going to go into it. Here's the first time I'm doing a deep dive and I'm like, you know what,
拖车里有七套服装，这事根本没发生过。我们每天连着五天都得穿同一套衣服。我是说，他们洗过，伙计们。他们洗过了。你知道的，不过对啊，我们每天都穿一样的。没错。但走进去的时候，我的小衣柜里塞满了所有这些衣服。我不得不回去看一眼，然后心想：等等，什么？哦，对了，那是带有电脑滴答声的冷开场。这抓得太好了。然后我们还有一段来自阿曼达·蒂格（Amanda Teague）的好玩留言，她说，我的心理学教授用这一集的冷开场来教我们巴浦洛夫理论。哦天哪。好吧，昨晚我读了很多关于巴浦洛夫的资料。我不会深入讲的。这是我第一次深入研究，然后我想，你知道吗，
you guys? It was fascinating. It's a whole podcast in itself. Well, now I'm intrigued. Okay, I will read one thing that I discovered. Okay. You know what? It's a shallow dive. Give me a shallow dive. Pavlov studied a lot about conditioning and how we react to things, how we can have involuntary reactions to stress or pain, or like the cues that Jim was doing to Dwight with the chime, and then you get a treat. Okay. This is the part I found really fascinating. They began to study trans-marginal inhibitions, the body's natural response of shutting down when exposed to overwhelming stress or pain. I mean, I guess like going into shock. Yeah. Yeah. Like when your body just shuts down. Research showed that different temperaments move through the
你们大家？这太吸引人了。这本身就是一个完整的播客。好吧，现在我感兴趣了。好吧，我读一个我发现的东西。好吧。你知道吗？这是一次浅尝辄止。给我来个浅尝辄止吧。巴浦洛夫对条件反射以及我们如何对事物做出反应进行了大量研究，研究我们如何对压力或疼痛产生不自主的反应，或者像吉姆用铃声对德wight（德怀特）做的那些暗示，然后你会得到一块点心。好吧。这是我觉得非常迷人的部分。他们开始研究超极限抑制，即身体在面对压倒性的压力或疼痛时，自然产生的关闭反应。我是说，我猜就像陷入休克一样。对。对。就像你的身体直接关机了一样。研究表明，不同的气质会以不同的节奏经历这些
responses at different times. I thought this was fascinating because you know something might happen traumatic in your life and you and the members of your family or your friends all experience it a little bit differently. Yeah. And you travel through stress and pain differently. Pavlov commented that the most basic inherited difference of people as they travel through stress and pain was how soon they reach the shutdown point and that people that are quick to shut down have a fundamentally different type of nervous system. Like on a cellular level, they have a different nervous system. I guess this is why it needs a massive deep dive. Well, that's a shallow dive that's making me want to dive into the deep end. I'm going to start ordering more books.
反应，时间各不相同。我觉得这太迷人了，因为你知道生活中可能会发生一些创伤性的事情，而你以及你的家人或朋友都会有略微不同的体验。是的。而且你们经历压力和疼痛的方式也不同。巴浦洛夫评论说，人们在经历压力和疼痛时，最基本的遗传差异在于他们多快会到达关闭点，而且那些很快关闭的人拥有根本不同类型的神经系统。就像在细胞层面上，他们拥有不同的神经系统。我想这就是为什么这需要进行一次深入的大研究。好吧，这是一次浅尝辄止，却让我想要一头扎进深水区。我打算开始订购更多的书了。
I haven't gotten my books yet about Jan Levinson Gould's name, psychology people yet, but I'm waiting. You have a lot to read, lady. You're going to be very busy. All right. Well, should we move into the meat of this episode, the spam of this episode? You reminded me when you said that of like Michael like, who wants my meat? Yes, let's get into the meat of this episode. We're at the church. Phyllis's wedding party is out on the steps being photographed. Michael is trying to squeeze himself into these pictures. The photographer does that great bit where he's like, you know what? Just Phyllis and her parents, but then also the bridesmaids and also you too. Everyone but Michael. Well, people wrote in Sidney Pappas, Henry Wengard, Tara S, James G,
我还没收到关于简·莱文森·戈尔德（Jan Levinson Gould）的名字以及心理学之类书籍呢，但我正在等。你有好多书要读啊，女士。你可有得忙了。好了。那么，我们该进入这一集的重头戏、这一集的SPAM了吗？你这么说让我想起了迈克尔那种“谁想要我的肉？”的表现。没错，让我们进入这一集的重头戏。我们到了教堂。菲莉丝的婚礼派对正在台阶上拍照。迈克尔正试图把自己挤进这些照片里。摄影师奉献了那段精彩的戏码，他说：你知道吗？只有菲莉丝和她的父母，但也加上伴娘们，还有你们俩。除了迈克尔之外所有人。好吧，人们写信来，悉尼·帕帕斯（Sidney Pappas）、亨利·温加德（Henry Wengard）、塔拉·S（Tara S）、詹姆斯·G（James G），
and Emily Langsham all want to know who played Phyllis's bridesmaids and family, were they all actors? Were any of them her real family members like Mindy's parents and Diwali? No, they were all actors. Her main sister that we see throughout the episode was played by Maley Flanagan and the photographer in the scene was played by John F. Schaefer. So those are just a couple of the guest stars. You know, Maley Flanagan is a great improv sketch actress and she performed with Wayne Wilderson and Nancy Walls before she was Nancy Carell. OMG. Well, next up, Michael explains that he is part of the wedding party because Phyllis has asked him to push her father down the aisle. So he's basically giving away the bride. And it's a big day for Phyllis,
和埃米莉·兰格姆（Emily Langsham）都想知道是谁扮演了菲莉丝的伴娘和家人，他们全都是演员吗？其中有没有人是她的现实生活家人，就像明迪（Mindy）的父母和排灯节那一集里的一样？不，他们全都是演员。我们在整集中看到的那位主要的姐姐是由梅利·弗拉纳根（Maley Flanagan）扮演的，而场景中的摄影师则由约翰·F·谢弗（John F. Schaefer）扮演。所以这些只是几位客串明星。你知道，梅利·弗拉纳根是一位出色的即兴小品女演员，在成为南希·卡瑞尔之前，她曾和韦恩·威尔德森（Wayne Wilderson）以及南希·沃尔斯（Nancy Walls）一起表演过。天哪。好吧，接下来，迈克尔解释说他是婚礼派对的一员，因为菲莉丝邀请他推着她父亲走过过道。所以他基本上是在代替父亲将新娘交出去。这对菲莉丝来说是个大日子，
but it's also just a really big day for him. He's employer of the bride. Well, then Phyllis has a talking head explaining the reason why she asked Michael to be in the wedding. She said she is going to get a six week vacation. Yeah. A six week honeymoon and that's never been done. So she had her motives. She did. And she's going to pay for it. She will. Decision. Nothing really is free, guys. Nothing comes for free. Well, then Pam has a talking head where she says Phyllis used the same invitations as her and Roy. There's a big P and a big R. I have a question for you about this because you hold it up. Yeah. I took a screen grab. I looked at it. So you remember your save the date that you handed Angela Martin in conflict resolution?
但对他来说这也是个非常重大的日子。他是新娘的雇主。好吧，接着菲莉丝有一个独白镜头，解释了她邀请迈克尔参加婚礼的原因。她说她要度一个为期六周的假期。对。一个六周的蜜月，这是史无前例的。所以她有她自己的动机。她确实有。而且她打算为此买单。她会的。这个决定。伙计们，没有什么真的是免费的。天下没有免费的午餐。好吧，接着帕姆有一个独白镜头，她说菲莉丝用了跟她和罗伊一样的请柬。上面有一个大P和一个大R。关于这个我有个问题要问你，因为你把它举起来了。对。我截了屏。我看了看。所以你还记得你在《冲突解决》里交给安吉拉·马丁的那份“请您留出时间”卡片吗？
Yeah. That was like shades of purple. That was a save the date. That's different from an invitation. But didn't we say that Pam's bridesmaids were going to have like lilac dresses or something at one point? Yeah. Like purple was her color. Purple's not here today, guys. There's orange turquoise. Yeah, you're right. There's a big jump from whatever her save the date idea was to what her wedding was going to be. Yeah. Some changes were made. You're right. Yeah. It ends up being more bluey. But then in Pam's wedding to Jim, she goes back to lilac. I know. I expected to see more purple people. That's all I'm saying. Well, then Stanley, Jim and Karen arrive. And we find out that they've both purchased toasters. Yes. I called it the dueling toasters. Stanley is really,
对。那是那种紫色的色调。那是“请您留出时间”通知。这和请柬不同。但我们之前不是说过，帕姆的伴娘会在某个时刻穿丁香紫之类颜色的裙子吗？对。就像紫色是她的代表色。伙计们，今天这里可没有紫色。这里有橙色、青色。对，你说的对。从她当时构思的“请您留出时间”卡片，到她实际的婚礼，这之间跨度可真大。是的。有些地方做出了改变。你说的对。对。结果变得更偏向蓝色了。但在帕姆和吉姆的婚礼上，她又回到了丁香紫。我知道。我本期望看到更多穿紫色的人呢。我只想说这个。好吧，接着斯坦利、吉姆和卡伦到了。然后我们发现他们俩都买了两台烤面包机。是的。我管这叫决斗烤面包机。斯坦利真的，
really annoyed. Carissa, Kaitlyn, Nicole, Kimberly, and Angela all said Stanley bought Phyllis a toaster for her wedding present. Do you think it's the same toaster that he bought for Pam and Roy's wedding that he couldn't return and now he's re-gifting it? 100%. Yes. I think that's part of the joke. Yeah. I wouldn't be surprised if it's in the same wrapping. He just put it on a shelf. I feel like Karen and Jim checked the registry. They picked the toaster. Maybe Stanley checked the registry and he's like, oh, she wants a toaster. I've got a toaster over here. I need to unload. Yeah. So imagine, you know, Jim and Karen's surprise. They're like, well, wait, it said it was still available on the registry. What the heck? I think that's why we
真的很恼火。卡里莎（Carissa）、凯特琳（Kaitlyn）、妮可（Nicole）、金伯利（Kimberly）和安吉拉都说斯坦利给菲莉丝买了一台烤面包机作为结婚礼物。你觉得这会不会就是他给帕姆和罗伊的婚礼买的那台、退不掉现在又拿来转送的烤面包机？百分之百。是的。我觉得这也是笑点的一部分。对。如果它还包在同一个包装里，我一点都不会觉得奇怪。他只是把它搁在架子上了。我觉得卡伦和吉姆核对过礼物登记册了。他们挑了烤面包机。也许斯坦利核对过登记册，然后他想：哦，她想要烤面包机。我这正好有一台烤面包机。我得把它处理掉。对。所以想象一下，你知道，吉姆和卡伦有多惊讶。他们心想：嗯，等等，登记册上说这还没人买呢。搞什么鬼？我想这就是为什么
get the dueling toasters. I love it. Next, Dwight and Angela arrive separately, but they run into each other in the parking lot. He tells her she looks as beautiful as the Queen of England. This is apparently a very high compliment. Angela really loves it. And then she insists that they, you know, they can't walk in the same. And she's like, don't linger, break left, left. And Jenna, part of that was improvised because I remember that on the day. And Rayne and I had a lot of fun being so silly in that parking lot. But I have to talk a minute about my outfit. Oh, well, you're going to make Hunter Sexton and Kennedy McAllister very happy because they want to know all about it. I remember Wardrobe saying that this was vintage, that they, it was like a
我们会看到这场“决斗烤面包机”的戏码。我太喜欢了。接下来，德怀特和安吉拉分别到达，但他们在停车场偶遇了。他告诉她，她美得就像英国女王。这显然是极高的赞美。安吉拉非常喜欢。然后她坚持说他们，你知道的，他们不能一起走进去。她还说：别磨蹭，向左突破，向左。詹娜，这其中有一部分是即兴发挥的，因为我还记得当时的情形。雷恩和我那天在那个停车场里玩得非常开心，傻乎乎的。但我得花一分钟说说我的衣服。哦，好吧，你这会让亨特·塞克斯顿（Hunter Sexton）和肯尼迪·麦卡利斯特（Kennedy McAllister）非常高兴，因为他们想了解关于这套衣服的一切。我记得服装组说过这是复古款，他们，这就像是
vintage suit that they found. It was very much like Jacqueline Kennedy, right? Yes. Jacqueline Kennedy for her husband's inauguration 1961 wore a pillbox hat and wore this cloth sort of wool coat. This was radical at the time. I looked it up because everyone would have been wearing mink, mink coats, mink hats. And there's Jacqueline in like cloth and wool. It's like, what? Oh, and I forever in my brain thought that her pillbox hat and dress were a shade of blue on that day. Are they not? No, no. So this was so cool. I looked up to see who made her hat. It was made by Halston. And when I did, I found out all of this information. Most people think it was blue, because at the time, I guess color films struggled to match real hues and photos.
他们找到的一套复古西装。这非常像杰奎琳·肯尼迪，对吧？是的。杰奎琳·肯尼迪在1961年她丈夫的就职典礼上戴了一顶药盒帽，并穿着这种呢子大衣。这在当时相当激进。我查过资料，因为当时所有人都会穿着水貂皮大衣、水貂皮帽子。而杰奎琳却穿着粗呢和羊毛衣服。就好像在说：什么？哦，而且我脑海里一直以为她当天的药盒帽和裙子是某种蓝色的。难道不是吗？不，不是。所以这太酷了。我查了一下是谁制作了她的帽子。那是出自哈尔ston（Halston）之手。当我查到时，我发现了所有这些信息。大多数人以为那是蓝色的，因为当时我猜彩色胶卷很难在照片中还原真实的色调。
But this dress is actually at the John F. Kennedy Presidential Library and Museum. That's where this outfit is stored. And it is in fact beige, beige, not blue. She wore a beige pillbox hat and a beige coat. Whoa. Yes. And if you look up this image in so many images, it's blue, except if you look at the cover of Life Magazine from the inauguration, it is beige. I mean, I'm a little surprised she wore beige to an inauguration. I know. I thought so too. She did have a mink. What do you think? Call it that you put your hands in? Stole? Stole? Is that what it's called? Stole? I don't know. Is it a muff? Is it a muff? A muff? No, muffs are for your ears. It's a handful. It was like a mink, brown mink ball,
但这件裙子实际上保存在约翰·F·肯尼迪总统图书馆暨博物馆里。这套衣服就存放在那里。而且它实际上是米色的，是米色，而不是蓝色。她戴了一顶米色的药盒帽，穿着一件米色的大衣。哇。是的。如果你在很多图片中搜索这个形象，它确实是蓝色的，除非你看就职典礼那一期的《生活》杂志封面，那是米色的。我是说，她在就职典礼上穿米色衣服，这让我有点惊讶。我知道。我也这么觉得。她的确有一件水貂皮。你觉得叫什么来着，就是你把手塞进去的那种？小围巾？长围巾？那是叫这个名字吗？小围巾？我不知道。那是毛手筒吗？毛手筒？不，毛手筒是戴在耳朵上的。那是抓在手里的。就像一个水貂皮球，棕色的水貂皮球，
and you put your hands in it. I know exactly what you're talking about. And I just, you can tell you and I are on the cutting edge of fashion. A mink ball. She had a mink ball. She had a mink ball. She put her hands in. And the collar of her coat was trimmed in the same color mink as the ball she put her hands in. But the whole outfit was beige, very bold. And then the thing that Halston, I think, would really want you to know, because he did an interview about it, is that he spent hours shaping that hat so it would have a perfect rounded dome top. And then when she went outside, the wind began to blow and she had to put her hand on top to hold the hat and it dented it in the middle. Wait. The shape of the hat that I've become,
然后你把手塞进去。我完全知道你在说哪种。而且我，你能看出你和我正站在时尚的最前沿。一个水貂皮球。她有一个水貂皮球。她有一个水貂皮球。她把手塞了进去。而且她大衣的领子边缘装饰的水貂皮颜色，和她把手塞进去的那个球是一样的。但整套服装都是米色的，非常大胆。然后是哈尔ston（Halston）大概真的很想让你们知道的一点，因为他曾就此接受过采访，那就是他花了几个小时来定型那顶帽子，好让它有一个完美的圆顶顶部。然后当她走到室外时，风开始刮起来，她不得不把手按在帽子顶部来固定住它，结果把它中间给按凹进去了。等等。我脑海中定型的、
like, that's burned in my brain was a mistake because she had to flatten it. She had to hold it to her head. She didn't mean to. It was blowing off, so she grabbed it. And that action put a dent in it. And so it was photographed the whole entire day. This was right at the beginning as she walked out. So it was photographed the whole day with this dent in it. And I mean, within, you know, several days, all across America, people were selling this dented hat to match Jackie's Pillbox hat. I cannot believe that her Pillbox hat was supposed to be rounded. Oh yeah, it's supposed to be like a little dome.
已经烙印在我脑子里的帽子形状，竟然是个失误，因为她不得不把它压平？她不得不把它按在头上。她不是故意的。帽子快被风吹走了，所以她一把抓住了它。而那个动作在帽子上留下了一个凹痕。于是整整一天它都是带着这个凹痕被拍照的。这正好发生在刚走出门的初期。所以它一整天被拍下来的时候都有这个凹痕。我是说，在（你知道的）几天之内，全美各地的人们都在出售这种带有凹痕的帽子来模仿杰基的药盒帽。我简直不敢相信她的药盒帽原本应该是圆顶的。哦，对，它本来应该像个小圆顶的。
I have to say, I think God sent that wind that day because a domed hat would have just looked so silly. But a dented hat. I think the dent was the right move. I don't know. All right. Halston, put on your earmuffs. I'm just saying sometimes there are acts of serendipity. Jenna thinks the dent was ordained. I don't know. Well, after this scene, Angela, we have a Dwight talking head that will become so relevant and important later at the end of the series. He explains that the shrewds have a tradition of getting married while standing in their own graves.
我得说，我觉得上帝那天是故意派那阵风来的，因为一个圆顶的帽子看起来可能会傻乎乎的。但一顶带凹痕的帽子。我觉得那个凹痕才是神来之笔。我不知道。好吧。哈尔ston，戴上你的耳套吧。我只是说，有时候会有巧合的奇迹。詹娜觉得那个凹痕是命中注定的。我不知道。好吧，在这场戏之后，安吉拉，我们有一个德怀特的独白镜头，这在后来剧集的结尾会变得极其相关且重要。他解释说，施鲁特家族有个传统，那就是站在他们自己的坟墓里举行婚礼。
And we are not going to forget this later when Dwight finally marries. We'll get there, but people had to help me in that hole. Well, so everyone's sort of filtering in. They're signing the guest book. Yada yada. In the meantime, Michael is checking in on Phyllis. Mm-hmm. He comes into the room. He wants to make sure she's all right. Yeah. He's really taken his role seriously as employer of the bride. Mm-hmm. This scene is absolutely fantastic. It's famous. It's famous. You know, Ken talked a little bit about how much they laughed while they
而我们以后在德怀特终于结婚时绝不会忘记这一点的。我们到时候会说到那儿，不过人们得帮我弄那个洞。好吧，所以大家都陆续进场了。他们在签嘉宾簿。巴拉巴拉。与此同时，迈克尔正在查看菲莉丝的情况。嗯哼。他走进了房间。他想确保她一切正常。是的。他真的很认真地对待自己作为“新娘雇主”的角色。嗯哼。这场戏绝对棒极了。太出名了。太出名了。你知道，肯（Ken）曾稍微聊过他们在拍这场戏时笑得有多开心。我们有很多人写信来。
were doing this scene. We had a lot of people write in. Kat, Marilee, Emily, Stephanie, and Dan all wanted to know if any of the Michael and Phyllis dialogue in this dressing room scene was improvised, specifically the word pungent. Well, guys, that was all in the script. They performed this almost exactly as scripted. I think that just tells you how well-written this scene is, but we had to ask Phyllis what it was like to film this scene. That scene was unbelievable. We had the best time. I don't know how many times we had to stop to start over, because there was one word in particular that we just could not get through,
卡特（Kat）、玛丽莉（Marilee）、埃米莉（Emily）、斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）和丹（Dan）都想知道，在化妆室这场戏中，迈克尔和菲莉丝的台词是否有即兴发挥的部分，特别是“pungent（刺鼻的/辛辣的）”这个词。好吧，伙计们，那全都在剧本里。他们几乎完全按照剧本演出了这一幕。我想这恰恰说明了这场戏写得有多好，但我们不得不去问问菲莉丝，拍摄这场戏是什么感觉。那场戏简直难以置信。我们度过了最棒的时光。我都不知道我们停下来重新开始过多少次，因为有一个词特别戳我们笑点，让我们怎么也演不下去，
and that was pungent. Every time Steve said the word pungent, he would break out into this high-pitched cackle, and then I would start laughing, and then all of a sudden we heard the video village and the sound people outside the door, because we were in a small dressing room area with just the camera guy and a sound boom. I'm not even sure if the boom guy was in there, so we could hear them cackling and laughing on the outside, so we had to stop. They had to move. They had to go down to the bottom of the stairs and set up down there. I couldn't breathe. I was laughing so hard. I couldn't breathe. He was laughing so hard, and we took, I don't know how many times we started over, and it was all because of the word
那个词就是“pungent”。每当史蒂夫（Steve）说出“pungent”这个词时，他就会爆发出这种高音调的咯咯笑声，然后我就会开始笑，紧接着突然之间我们能听到门外的视频村（监视器区域）和音响人员的声音，因为我们当时身处一个很小的化妆室区域，里面只有摄像师和一个收音杆师。我甚至不确定收音师当时在不在里面，所以我们能听到他们在外面咯咯笑、哈哈大笑，于是我们不得不停下来。他们不得不换地方。他们不得不走到楼梯底部并在那里架设设备。我简直喘不过气来。我笑得太厉害了。我喘不过气来。他笑得太厉害了，我们也不知道重新开始拍了多少次，而这一切全都是因为“pungent”这个词。
pungent. It's so pungent. It makes me laugh to think of it now, and the only way I found, because I didn't want to keep ruining the scene from laughing, and the only way I got through that scene was to hold my breath. When I wasn't talking, I literally had to suck it up and hold my breath, otherwise we just couldn't get through it. It's a very fond memory and one of the best that I can have in my entire life. It was a great few moments there, so when you hear the word pungent, know that all hell broke loose every time we said it. Oh man, I love that so much. I know. I know. This scene made us laugh at the table read, and then it made us fall apart when we watched it. What really got me was the word pungent, but it was the breath that Steve took
这太刺鼻了。现在想起来还是让我忍不住发笑，而我找到的唯一方法——因为我不想一直因为笑场而毁了这场戏——我挺过这场戏的唯一方法就是憋气。当我不用说话时，我 literalmente（字面意义上）必须把气吸进去然后憋住，否则我们根本无法完成拍摄。这是一段非常美好的回忆，也是我一生中能拥有的最棒的回忆之一。当时有那么几个绝佳的时刻，所以每当你听到“pungent”这个词时，就知道我们每次一说它，场面就会彻底失控。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个了。我知道。我知道。这场戏在围读剧本时就让我们笑个不停，然后在看成片时又让我们笑得崩溃。真正戳中我的不仅是“pungent”这个词，而是史蒂夫在说出它之前吸的那口气。
before he said it. Yeah. Oh man, I wish I could have been a fly on the wall. I would have ruined the tics even as a fly. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, this scene was supposed to go on. Bob Vance is supposed to come to the door. Yes, it's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Oh my gosh. Well, I guess they couldn't get through that part either. Bob comes to the door, and he's like, you know, Michael's there, and Michael's like, and he's like, oh, what is that smell? And Michael's like, that was Phyllis. She has some nerves, some wedding jitters. And Phyllis is like, it's not me. And Bob was like, I'm gonna go. Oh my gosh. I wish that was still in the episode, I have to say. It's really funny.
对。哦天哪，我真希望当时能做一只墙上的苍蝇。哪怕只是一只苍蝇，我也会把那些拍子给毁了。哦天哪。好吧，你知道的，这场戏原本应该继续下去的。鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance）本来应该走到门口。是的，这在DVD的删减片段里。哦天哪。好吧，我猜他们连那部分也演不下去了。鲍勃走到门口，然后他就，你知道的，迈克尔在那儿，迈克尔就，然后他说：哦，那是什么味道？迈克尔就说：那是菲莉丝。她有点紧张，有些结婚前的紧张情绪。然后菲莉丝就说：不是我。鲍勃就说：我要走了。哦天哪。我真希望这段还在正片里，我得说。这真的太搞笑了。
All right. Well, now Michael has a talking head that, you know, believe it or not, he's only ever been to one other wedding. Jenna, this made me sad. Oh, I can't deal with Michael's childhood. I know. It rips you up. It's too much for me. Well, he's only been to one other wedding, and it was his mom getting married to Jeff. Yeah. And there's a flashback video. It looks like maybe he peed his pants, you know? Oh, yes. Walking down the aisle is the ring bearer. And he runs out, and he says, I hate you. And anyway, it's clearly a traumatic experience for him. And Michael is carrying all of that in now to only the second wedding he's ever been to. Yeah. There's, there's so much this, this scene is really important, because it's meant to justify why Michael behaves
好了。好吧，现在迈克尔有一个独白镜头，你知道的，信不信由你，他一生中只去过另一场婚礼。詹娜，这让我感到难过。哦，我无法面对迈克尔的童年。我知道。太虐心了。对我和说太沉重了。好吧，他只去过另一场婚礼，那是他妈妈嫁给杰夫的婚礼。对。而且还有一个闪回视频。看起来他好像尿裤子了，你知道的？哦，是的。作为花童走过过道。然后他跑出去说：我恨你们。总之，这对他来说显然是一次痛苦的经历。而迈克尔把这一切都带到了他这辈子参加的仅有的第二场婚礼中。是的。这里有，这里有太多，这场戏真的很重要，因为它的目的是为了证明为什么迈克尔整天会有那样的举动。
the way he does all day. You know, Michael's trying to heal an old wound here. Yeah. He's trying to make up for the one other horrible wedding he's ever been to. You know, I feel like this is very relatable. If you had a horrible experience back in high school, but now you've made it big and you're going back to your reunion, you're trying to make up for all that lost time. And I think that's a little similar here with Michael. I think the other thing going on here too is that once again, Michael sees his coworkers as his family. So he really thinks he has a bigger role in this wedding than he does. Yes. So now folks are entering the church, right? They're arriving for the ceremony and Dwight and Jim have this exchange. Dwight's like,
你知道，迈克尔是在这里试图治愈一道旧伤。是的。他试图弥补他曾经经历过的唯一那场糟糕透顶的婚礼。你知道，我觉得这非常具有共鸣。如果你在高中时有过糟糕的经历，但现在你混出名堂了，要回去参加同学聚会，你就会想把所有失去的时间都弥补回来。我觉得迈克尔现在的情况有点类似。我觉得这里发生的另一件事是，迈克尔再次把他的同事们看作是他的家人。所以他真的觉得自己在这场婚礼中扮演的角色比实际要大得多。是的。所以现在人们开始进教堂了，对吧？他们抵达现场参加典礼，德怀特和吉姆有了这样一段对话。德怀特说：
who are all these people? Yeah, he clearly doesn't like crowds. He says he has this line. He says, we need a new plague. There's too many people. Did you say plague? Plague. Plague. Plague. There's an A. Have you said plague your whole life? Yeah, plague. We need a new plague. Oh my god. I'm saying plague. Plague. It's a plague. Plague. I'm saying plague. I cannot believe I'm saying something correctly and you're not. This is, let's go buy a lottery ticket. Anything can happen. All right. He says we need a new plague. Thank you. Well, we had a fan question from Brianna Everett who wants to know, because it's feeling very relevant now, did Dwight improvise that line about the plague? No, that was scripted. I mean, this episode was really well written.
这些人都是谁啊？是的，他显然不喜欢人群。他说了一句台词。他说：我们需要一场新的瘟疫。人太多了。你刚才说的是“瘟疫”（plague）吗？瘟疫（plague）。瘟疫。瘟疫。有个A。你一辈子都这么说吗？对，瘟疫。我们需要一场新的瘟疫。哦天哪。我说的是瘟疫（plague）。瘟疫。是瘟疫。瘟疫。我说的是瘟疫。我简直不敢相信我说的竟然是对的，而你不是。这，我们去买张彩票吧。什么都有可能发生。好吧。他说我们需要一场新的瘟疫。谢谢。好吧，我们有一个来自布里安娜·埃弗雷特（Brianna Everett）的粉丝提问，她想知道——因为现在感觉非常应景——德怀特关于瘟疫的那句台词是即兴发挥的吗？不，那是剧本写好的。我是说，这一集真的写得太好了。
It really was. Yes. So there's, I feel like there's a lot of lines that feel like they're improvised, but they were written. That was written. So now Dwight has this in his head that people are crashing the wedding and he's going to have to go find them, Jenna. He's a man on a mission and everyone else is arriving and they're sort of like mingling and talking. Yes. Kevin introduces himself to Toby's date who he does not believe Toby met at the gym. He's like, basically implying she's a hired escort. This is classic pervy Kevin. We had some fan questions from Cassidy Hill, Allison Lolis and Lisa Rice. Is Toby's date a hired escort? Or did Toby really meet this beautiful woman at a gym? And why don't we ever see her again?
确实如此。是的。所以我觉得有很多台词听起来像是即兴发挥的，但其实都是写好的。那是写好的。所以现在德怀特脑子里认准了有人在搅乱婚礼，他得去找他们，詹娜。他是一个肩负使命的男人，而其他人正在抵达，他们正聚在一起寒暄交谈。是的。凯文向托比的女伴做自我介绍，他不相信托比是在健身房认识她的。他的潜台词基本上是暗示她是一个被雇用的三陪女。这就是典型的色鬼凯文。我们收到了来自卡西迪·希尔（Cassidy Hill）、艾莉森·洛利斯（Allison Lolis）和丽莎·赖斯（Lisa Rice）的粉丝提问。托比的女伴是一个被雇用的三陪女吗？还是托比真的在健身房遇到了这位美丽的女士？为什么我们再也没有见过她？
Well, I'll tell you. I don't know why we never see her again. Well, there was a talking head in the script after she catches the bouquet at the end. Toby says that she's a pediatric nurse. Yes. But that was cut out of the episode. That is in the DVD box set. There you go. So it was a deleted scene. I believe that she's a pediatric nurse. Yeah. Well, also we have a quick moment, a little joke that I really like, which is that Kelly has worn white to the wedding. It looks like a wedding dress with a tiara. I know. Yeah. Tiara, tiara. I'm going to let that one slide. All right. Well, now it is Michael's moment. He's about to walk Phyllis down the aisle. He's about to start pushing Albert. Yes, folks. Did you hear that? Albert. I got into a big
好吧，我来告诉你。我不知道为什么我们再也没见过她。好吧，在片尾她接住捧花之后，剧本里其实有一个独白镜头。托比说她是一名儿科护士。是的。但那段被从正片里剪掉了。那段在DVD套装里。给你。所以那是个删减片段。我相信她是一名儿科护士。是的。嗯，此外我们还有一个简短的时刻，一个我很喜欢的笑话，那就是凯莉竟然穿了白色去参加婚礼。看起来就像是一件带着皇冠的婚纱。我知道。是的，皇冠，小皇冠。我就暂且放过这个不纠结了。好吧，现在是迈克尔的高光时刻了。他马上要挽着菲莉丝走过过道了。他马上要开始推阿尔伯特了。是的，伙计们！你们听到了吗？阿尔伯特。我和家人展开了一场激烈的
debate with my family. They were positive that he was saying Albert. And I said, no, it's Albert. I know I'm hearing Albert. It's weird because her father's name is Albert. And then there's Uncle Al. But it's Albert. Albert. Correct. Thank you. Well, as the doors open, we reveal Phyllis in her wedding dress and Pam turns to camera and says, oh my God, that's my dress. So she has stolen the invitations and now her wedding dress. We had a fan question, Angela, from Kaylee Connolly. And I'm going to need your input here. Okay. She says throughout this episode, Pam realizes that Phyllis has stolen all of her wedding details. And then she's wearing the same dress. Well, in the season finale, Angela looks like she's wearing the same dress that Phyllis wore
辩论。他们言之凿凿地认为他说的是阿尔伯特（Albert）。而我说，不对，是阿尔伯特。我知道我听到的是阿尔伯特。这很奇怪，因为她父亲的名字叫阿尔伯特。然后还有阿尔叔叔。但那是阿尔伯特。阿尔伯特。没错。谢谢。好吧，随着大门打开，我们看到菲莉丝穿着她的婚纱出现，而帕姆转身对着镜头说：哦天哪，那是我的裙子。所以她不仅偷了请柬，现在连婚纱也一起偷了。安吉拉，我们有一个来自凯莉·康纳利（Kaylee Connolly）的粉丝提问。我这里需要你的输入。好的。她说在这一整集中，帕姆意识到菲莉丝偷了她所有的婚礼筹备细节。然后她还穿着同一件裙子。嗯，在季终集里，安吉拉看起来好像穿着和菲莉丝在婚礼上穿的
in her wedding to Dwight. Was this planned? Okay. So I wrote this down too. You guys, when we were watching it, I was watching it with the kids. I said, oh my gosh, that's my dress. And then the kids were like, no, you mean it's Pam's dress? I said, no, it's my dress. And I have all these photos on my phone. I took a ton of photos for the finale, Jenna, of my wardrobe fitting, all of it. It is almost identical. I don't think this was planned, obviously. I don't think Angela Martin would try to emulate Phyllis's dress. I think it was by chance. But you guys, it is so similar. I had a little lace shawl jacket thing. It didn't come long sleeve. Like Phyllis's goes all the way to her, her wrists, you know, mine went sort of just to the
一模一样的裙子。这是计划好的吗？好吧。所以我这也记下来了。伙计们，我们在看的时候，我是和孩子们一起看的。我说：哦天哪，那是我的裙子。然后孩子们就说：不对，你是说那是帕姆的裙子？我说：不，那是我的裙子。我的手机里有所有这些照片。詹娜，为了季终集，我拍了超级多的照片，关于我的服装试穿，全都有。这几乎是一模一样的。我认为这显然不是计划好的。我不认为安吉拉·马丁会试图去效仿菲莉丝的裙子。我觉得这纯属巧合。但伙计们，它真的太像了。我也查过资料。我的电脑上并排放着照片。它们太像了，就像裙子的剪裁简直一模一样。太疯狂了。我知道。好吧。所以他们正在走过过道。当他们走到大约一半路程时，阿尔伯特不知怎么地开始试着站起来了。他好像想要尝试，对吧？这是他女儿的婚礼。菲莉丝开心极了。她开始微笑，所有人都鼓掌了。而迈克尔则是一副：绝无可能吧。他只有这一个任务。
elbow area. And then we had a strapless kind of dress. I do not have a broad ribbon band on mine, like hers. But it's super similar. I looked it up too. I had pictures side by side on my computer. They are so, it's like the cut of the dress is so similar. Crazy. I know. Okay. So they're walking down the aisle. And as they get about halfway down, Albert is sort of moved to stand up. He's like, he wants to try, right? It's his daughter's wedding. And Phyllis is so delighted. She just starts to smile and everyone applauds. And Michael is like, no freaking way. He had one job. He had one job. And they just took it away from him. Yes. And he just reverts back to that little boy who didn't get to walk down the aisle with the rings. And the dog took his spot. So Michael is
他只有这一个任务。而他们就这样把它从他手里夺走了。是的。然后他又退化成了那个没能拿着戒指走过过道的、可怜的小男孩。当时狗狗抢了他的位置。所以迈克尔就只能
just watching Phyllis and her father walk down the aisle to all of this applause. What he does is just sort of awkwardly pushes slash drags the wheelchair down the aisle behind them. So here's my question, Jenna, because you have the script. I sort of figured in the script, I would say Michael awkwardly walks behind them. Was that dragging of the wheelchair? Was that Steve or was that in the script? Oh, Angela, you are not the only person to wonder. So I did look this up because Camille, Sarah, Dylan, Megan and Katie all asked the same question. Yes, it was scripted. Here's what it says in the script. It says, Michael can't figure out how to undo the lock on the wheelchair. So he drags it down while still doing a traditional wedding walk. Amazing.
眼睁睁看着菲莉丝和她父亲在雷鸣般的掌声中走过过道。他做的事情就是极其尴尬地推着/拖着轮椅跟在他们身后走过过道。所以我的问题是，詹娜，既然你有剧本。我原本以为在剧本里，我会写：迈克尔尴尬地跟在他们身后走。那种拖着轮椅的动作，那是史蒂夫自己加的，还是本来就写在剧本里的？哦，安吉拉，你可不是唯一一个好奇的人。所以我确实查了这个，因为卡米拉（Camille）、莎拉（Sarah）、迪伦（Dylan）、梅根（Megan）和凯蒂（Katie）都问了同样的问题。是的，那是剧本里写好的。剧本里是这样写的。上面写着：迈克尔不知道怎么解开轮椅上的锁。所以他一边保持着传统的婚礼步态，一边把它拖着走。太惊人了。
Yeah. So all of that of him doing the like step together, step together. That was, you know, a script note. Well, we asked Phyllis about this moment. And here's what she had to say. One of the scenes that stood out in my mind was when I was walking down the aisle. And since I've never been married, to me, that was a real thrill. And then Michael, Steve, Michael, when he started dragging the wheelchair after my dad had gotten up and was going to walk me down the aisle and Michael was dragging the wheelchair, I could not keep a straight face. And I was so happy that the majority of the time, my back was to that to that action, because it was just hard to keep it in just the sound of the wheelchair dragging down the aisle. I remember that. I
是的。所以他那种“并步走、并步走”的动作，那是（你知道的）剧本注解。好吧，我们问了菲莉丝关于这个时刻的感受。以下是她的说法。我脑海中最突出的场景之一，就是当我走过过道的时候。由于我从来没结过婚，对我来说，那真是一次巨大的震撼。然后迈克尔——史蒂夫、迈克尔，当他在我爸爸站起来、准备带我走过过道之后，开始拖着轮椅走时，我根本没办法保持严肃的表情。而且我很庆幸绝大多数时候我的背是对着那个动作的，因为实在太难忍住不笑，光是听到轮椅拖过过道的那个声音。我还记得那个。我
remember it was very hard to get through. Jenna, I don't know if you remember, but I sat directly behind you. No. Yes. And we were tickled because between scenes, we could turn around and chat to each other. Well, it's funny because someone pointed out that it seemed like all of the Dunder Mifflin employees were on one side except for Pam. Yes. Usually there's a bride side and a groom side, but I guess we sat on the groom side. But I do remember I have such a memory of how beautiful the back of your hair looked. It looks so beautiful. I watched this episode and I just thought I looked fantastic. You did. I was like, oh my gosh. You did. My hair looks amazing. That dress, that color, that chocolatey color dress. I had never seen you in that color before,
记得要拍完这一段真的很难。詹娜，我不知道你还记不记得，我当时就坐在你正后方。没有吗？是的。我们觉得特别滑稽，因为在两场戏的间隙，我们可以转过身去和彼此聊天。好吧，很有趣的是，有人指出似乎所有邓德米夫林的员工都坐在同一侧，除了帕姆。是的。通常都会有新娘侧和新郎侧，但我想我们是坐在新郎侧了。不过我确实记得，我对你当时脑后头发的样子留下了深刻的印象。看起来太漂亮了。我看这一集时心想，我当时看起来简直棒极了。你确实很棒。我当时想：哦天哪。你确实。我的发型看起来太惊艳了。那条裙子，那个颜色，那个巧克力色的裙子。我以前从来没见过你穿那个颜色，
personally. Why don't I wear that color more is what I thought. I don't know. I feel like that color inspired me because that was the color of the dress I wore to the Golden Globes. Remember that time when we met Ben Affleck? Yeah. Yes. Yes. I was like, if Pam can wear it, I can wear it. Well, I noticed something else about the wedding guests. What? No, Geno and Leo. Bob Vance did not seem to invite any employees. So Phyllis invited all of her work friends, but I didn't see a big bunch of Vance refrigeration people. Well, you only know two of them really, Geno and Leo. Maybe Phyllis was like, those two will do something. They're always up to something. They're on my list now. They're on my no list. Yeah. Well, I'm sure Bob was like, we're inviting
个人而言。我当时想：我为什么不多穿那个颜色呢？我不知道。我觉得那个颜色启发了我，因为那正是我穿去金球奖颁奖典礼的裙子的颜色。还记得我们遇到本·阿弗莱克（Ben Affleck）的那次吗？是的。是的。我当时想：如果帕姆能穿，我也能穿。好吧，我还注意到了婚礼宾客的一些其他情况。什么？没有基诺（Geno）和利奥（Leo）。鲍勃·万斯似乎没有邀请任何员工。所以菲莉丝邀请了她所有的工作朋友，但我没看到一大群万斯冷冻公司的员工。好吧，你其实只认识其中两个，基诺和利奥。也许菲莉丝当时想的是：那两个家伙会搞出什么幺蛾子。他们总是在密谋什么。他们现在上我的黑名单了。他们上了我的“绝不邀请”名单。是的。好吧，我敢sure（确信）鲍勃当时的想法是：我们要邀请
Michael, but I can't bring Geno and Leo. I don't think Bob cared. Well, I don't know if you noticed in the line of groomsmen standing up there, there are a set of twins. Those are meant to be Bob's grown sons. Oh. It's in the script that Bob's twin sons are standing up for him. So he has his best friend and who gives a little bit of a speech later, and then his twin sons. And then I don't know who the other man is meant to be, but no Geno and Leo. So Phyllis is now a stepmom. Yeah. The minister is trying to finish the vows, but Michael jumps the gun and he pronounces Bob and Phyllis' man and wife. He had to get something in there. And it's crickets because the vows aren't finished, everyone. You know what the best job for Michael would have been is if he could have just
迈克尔，但我不能把基诺和利奥带来。我觉得鲍勃根本不在乎。好吧，我不知道你有没有注意到伴郎们的站队里，有一对双胞胎。那些设定是鲍勃成年的儿子们。哦。剧本里写了，鲍勃成年的双胞胎儿子在台上为他当伴郎。所以他有他最好的朋友——也就是稍后发表了一小段演讲的那位——然后是他的双胞胎儿子。接着我不知道另一个男的是谁设定的人选，但总之没有基诺和利奥。所以菲莉丝现在成了继母。是的。牧师正试图念完誓词，但迈克尔抢先一步，抢先宣布鲍勃和菲莉丝结为夫妻。他总得说点什么。结果现场一片死寂，因为誓词还没念完呢，伙计们。你知道对迈克尔来说最棒的工作是什么吗？就是如果他能
been the DJ at the reception. Just be the person who announces them in. Yes. For the first time, I'd like to introduce to you. Yes. That could have been it. Give him a microphone. It would be like at the dundies for him all over again. He could be like, and now for the first dance and all of that. Well, I don't know. I don't know if you should give Michael a microphone as we will see soon. Oh, yeah. Well, you you know what, Angela? I always like to give shoutouts to our guest actors. The minister was played by Rick Scary. And Michael does finally get it right. Everyone cheers. And he's he's a little happy with that moment. He's like, oh, good. And he should have just left it alone. He had his moment, Michael, but Michael can't leave it alone, you guys.
仅仅成为招待会上的DJ。只需做那个负责宣他们登场的人。是的。我隆重向大家介绍……是的。那就对了。给他一个话筒。对他的而言，这会像是又回到了邓迪奖颁奖典礼。他可以说：接下来是第一支舞，诸如此类。好吧，我不知道。我不知道你是否应该给迈克尔一个话筒，正如我们稍后会看到的。哦，是的。好吧，你知道吗，安吉拉？我总是喜欢对我们的客串演员表达感谢。牧师由里克·斯卡里（Rick Scary）扮演。而迈克尔最终还是说对了。大家都在欢呼。而他对那个时刻感到有点高兴。他心想：哦，太好了。他本该就此打住的。他已经拥有自己的高光时刻了，迈克尔，但迈克尔就是管不住自己，伙计们。
No. And it's all going to blow up at the reception. Alright, well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll talk about what happens. All right. So we are back. We're about to go to Phyllis and Bob's reception. And Angela, it is really hitting me that we were on location this entire episode. Jenna, I wrote about it in my journal. I said, we were on location all week, and we got to spend a lot of time in our trailers together because we had no quote, office set to call home. Oscar and I, Oscar and I played music and danced in my trailer. Oh, and John's trailer was Hangout Central. The guys were playing Madden football in there. And we went us gals and hung out in there too. Rain actually attempted to teach me how to play Madden. Oh, I was horrible. And he was so
不。而且这一切即将在招待会上彻底爆发。好吧，那我们休息一下。等我们回来，再聊聊接下来发生了什么。好吧，所以我们回来了。我们马上要去参加菲莉丝和鲍勃的招待会了，安吉拉，我真的深深意识到我们在这一整集中都是在实景外景地拍摄的。詹娜，我在日记里写过这个。我说过，我们一整周都在外景地拍摄，而且因为我们没有所谓的“办公室布景”可以当作大本营，所以我们有很多时间一起待在拖车里。奥斯卡和我，奥斯卡和我一起在我的拖车里放音乐、跳舞。哦，约翰的拖车是大家的“闲逛中心”。男人们在那里玩《麦登橄榄球》（Madden football）。我们女孩子们也过去一起待在那儿。雷恩甚至试图教我怎么玩《麦登》。哦，我玩得太烂了。而他却那么
patient. At one point, our second AD was trying to find us all. And when he came to John's trailer, it was John, Rain, Jenna, Rashida and me. Us gals took turns hosting lunch. Today, I hosted and I realized I spent the morning sprucing up my trailer. Isn't that crazy? I cleaned it and then I lit a candle like I was at home having people over for dinner. Of course you did. Oh my gosh, this is so cute. I think the thing that's striking me, Angela, is that it's true how little time we spent in our trailers when we were back on our Dunder Mifflin set because we would just hang out at our desks between scenes. Exactly. That's why I said we didn't have our office desks. So yeah. And I know a lot of these scenes, Jenna, if we weren't in them, they really wanted us to go to our trailer
有耐心。有一次，我们的第二副导演（2AD）试图找到我们所有人。当他来到约翰的拖车时，里面有约翰、雷恩、詹娜、拉什达（Rashida）和我。我们女孩子们轮流做东安排午餐。今天轮到我做东，我意识到我花了一整个上午把我的拖车打扮收拾了一番。是不是很疯狂？我把它打扫干净，还点了一支蜡烛，就像我在家里请客吃晚饭一样。你当然会这么做啦。哦天哪，这太可爱了。我觉得让我感触最深的一点，安吉拉，就是当我们回到邓德米夫林的布景时，我们在拖车里度过的时间是多么少，因为我们在两场戏之间总是直接在各自的办公桌旁闲晃。没错。这就是为什么我说我们没有办公室办公桌。所以，是的。而且我知道很多这些场景，詹娜，如果我们没有戏份，剧组真的希望我们回拖车去，
because they didn't want, you know, they didn't want to be looking for us all throughout the church. So when we weren't in scenes, they wanted us to go to our little base camp area. And we didn't do as much background work in this episode as you might think. They really crafted these shots and Ken kind of talked about that. He had a very specific shot list and he knew exactly what he wanted to see and when he wanted to see it. So if you weren't a part of that storytelling, you were back in the trailer. Yeah. Learning how to play Madden football from Rain Wolfson. I guess so. Now that you bring it up, I have a vague memory of Rain very patiently trying to teach you all the buttons on that controller. I was horrible. Back at the reception. I guess
因为他们不想（你知道的）到处找我们。所以当我们没有戏份时，他们希望我们待在各自的小基地区域里。而且我们在这一集里并没有做像你想象中那么多的背景工作。他们真的很精心设计了这些镜头，肯（Ken）也稍微聊过这个。他有一个非常具体的镜头清单，并且确切地知道他想看到什么、以及他想在什么时候看到。所以如果你不是那个讲故事环节的一部分，你就得回拖车去。是的。跟着雷恩·威尔森（Rain Wilson）学习如何玩《麦登橄榄球》。我想是的。经你这么一提，我隐约记起雷恩非常有耐心地试图教你手柄上的所有按键。我当时太烂了。回到招待会。我猜
on the way into the reception, they have a traditional receiving line. Everyone walks through. You have a nice little moment with Phyllis. Yes. I say that her dress is so white. It's almost blinding. I think I know what the implication is there. Yes. But did you notice that I have little lace gloves on? No. Yes. And I had to wear them the whole week and they drove me crazy. Well, you know, they would especially drive you crazy today because you cannot wear lace gloves and operate a smartphone. Oh right. I wouldn't be able to swipe up or do anything. No. That was my first thought. My first thought when you told me that. But then my other thought is, were they itchy? They were a little too long for my fingers. So I had this
在前往招待会的路上，他们有一个传统的迎宾队列。每个人都从那儿走过。你和菲莉丝有了一个美好的小互动。是的。我说她的裙子太白了。简直快把我闪瞎了。我想我知道那里的言外之意是什么。是的。但你注意到我戴着一副蕾丝小手套了吗？没有。是的。而且我那一整周都得戴着它们，快把我折磨疯了。好吧，你知道的，它们在今天绝对会更折磨疯你，因为你根本没办法戴着蕾丝手套去操作智能手机。哦，对哦。我连向上滑动或者做任何事情都做不到了。哦，天哪。那是我的第一反应。当你告诉我这件事时，我的第一反应就是这个。但我的另一个想法是：它们扎人吗？它们对我的手指来说稍微长了一点。所以我有了一截
little floppy bit. That's what she said. I have a deleted talking head where I show up to the church and it's one of the craziest shots. I meant to bring it up to Ken, dang it. It's like he put the camera on the ground, Jenna. And it's shooting up from the asphalt like under my chin. It's not super flattering. And I'm looking down and a high above my head is the cross in the steeple of the church. It's a very dramatic talking head where I basically say, you know, I like traditional weddings. So let's see what this one's going to be like. And as I'm doing it, I have black gloves on and I'm taking them off slowly. And as I do underneath are my lace gloves. I adore that detail. That is very funny. So people are milling about. People are kind of like, you
垂下来松垮垮的部分。那是她说的。我有一个被删掉的独白镜头，镜头里我到了教堂，那是一个最疯狂的镜头。我本打算跟肯提的，该死。就好像他把摄像机放在了地上，詹娜。然后从沥青路面上往上拍，正好拍到我的下巴底下。这并不是超级显瘦好看的角度。我往下看着，而在我头顶上方高高挂着的是教堂的十字架和尖顶。这是一个非常戏剧性的独白镜头，我基本上在里面说：你知道的，我喜欢传统的婚礼。所以让我们看看这场会是什么样的。当我这么做时，我戴着黑手套，然后慢慢把它脱掉。而当我脱掉时，露出了里面戴着的蕾丝手套。我太喜欢这个细节了。这真的太搞笑了。所以人们在四处闲逛。人们有点像，
know, checking out the food, they're walking around. Kelly finds Pam. And she is like, oh my God, you must be so miserable right now. Yeah. And Pam's like, I don't know, I'm fine. I'm okay. And she's like, well, she would be freaking out and getting drunk and telling someone she's pregnant. Pam's like, Pam's like, it's a lot of good ideas. I feel like Kelly is a friend of me. I feel like she's one of those types of gals. Like, clearly Pam is noticing all of this. She really doesn't want anyone to then like rub it in her face. But she's like, oh my God, are you so bummed out? Because they totally took your wedding and Roy's here and Jim's with someone else. I would be miserable. Yes, but it's all under the guise of like, are you okay? Yeah. She doesn't care if you're
你知道的，在查看食物，他们四处走动。凯莉找到了帕姆。她一副：哦天哪，你现在一定惨透了吧。是的。而帕姆则说：我不知道，我挺好的。我没事。然后凯莉就说：换作她的的话，肯定已经抓狂、开始酗酒、然后随便告诉谁自己怀孕了。帕姆就说：帕姆说，这全都是好主意。我觉得凯莉是个塑料姐妹花。我觉得她是那种类型的女孩。很显然帕姆注意到了这一切。她真的不希望任何人把这事往她脸上怼。但凯莉却一副：哦天哪，你难道不觉得沮丧透顶吗？因为他们完全抢了你的婚礼，而且罗伊也在这儿，吉姆又和别人在一起。我要是你的话肯定惨透了。是的，但这全都是以“你还好吗”这种伪装进行的。她才不管你是不是
okay. No, no, this is a gossip moment. Yeah. Well, Dwight is determined to find the wedding crashers Dwight finds an elderly guest at the buffet. He's like putting a roll in his pocket. I respect that move. I have put bread in my purse before. I've done it too. Yeah. Many times. Many times. I've done it with you. I don't like to be without food. I want to have a snack on me at all times. Okay. So Dwight thinks he's a wedding crusher. He starts asking him all these questions and the man is confused. And Dwight's like, that's it and kicks him out. He kicks him out. And that's when Michael checks in with Phyllis, who's like, is everything okay? He mentions he sent back the chicken because it was undercooked. Phyllis is like, it was fish. He's
行吧。不，不，这是八卦时刻。对。好吧，德怀特下定决心要找到婚礼不速之客，德怀特在自助餐区发现了一位年长的宾客。他好像把一个餐包放进了口袋里。我尊重这个举动。我以前也在钱包里塞过面包。我也干过。对。很多次。很多次。我还跟你一起干过。我不喜欢没有食物。我希望随时随地都有零食。好吧。所以德怀特以为他是婚礼不速之客。他开始问他各种问题，那个人一头雾水。德怀特就说，就是他，然后把他赶出去了。他把他赶出去了。就在这时，迈克尔去向菲莉丝了解情况，菲莉丝说，一切都好吗？他提到他把鸡肉退回去了，因为没熟透。菲莉丝说，那是鱼。他
like, I'm on it. Well, we had a fan question from Ashley Brooks. She wanted to know, did either of you have a funny story or a wild card guest like Michael at your weddings? You know, I didn't. But two people did have sex in the bushes at my wedding. I know one of them. It wasn't me. Well, I know both of them because they were guests at my wedding and they didn't come together. What? Oh, oh, that sounded weird. I don't know that much. I don't know that many details about their, about their rendezvous. I was like, deer in headlights. I was like, what? Oh dear. They didn't arrive to the wedding. Wedding together.
就像是，我来处理。好吧，我们有一个来自阿什莉·布鲁克斯的粉丝提问。她想知道，你们两个人的婚礼上，有没有像迈克尔那样好笑的故事或者意想不到的宾客？你知道，我没有。但有两个人确实在我婚礼的灌木丛里做爱了。我知道其中一个。那不是我。好吧，两个我都认识，因为他们都是我婚礼的宾客，而且他们不是一起来的。什么？哦，哦，听起来怪怪的。我知道得没那么多。关于他们俩的私会，我不知道那么多细节。我当时就像在强光灯前的鹿一样。我当时想，什么？天哪。他们没有一起来参加婚礼。
They hooked up at your wedding. Yes. Okay. Well, I can tell you at my wedding, we didn't have a random guest, but my husband really, really, really wanted to have a signature drink. He was like, so excited about it. I love a signature drink. I know. He did too. I was like, eh. But he wanted, he likes a Moscow mule, so he wanted to have the Moscow mule, but he wanted to use, is it bourbon? I'm going to get this wrong. It's actually called a Kentucky mule. They make it a little different, but he wanted everyone as their wedding favor to get a copper mug. Do you remember this, Jenna? I love my copper mug. Okay. You took yours home. Yeah. I told Josh, I was like, Josh, people are not going to realize they can take them home.
他们在你的婚礼上勾搭上了。对。好吧，我可以告诉你，在我的婚礼上，我们没有不速之客，但我丈夫真的、真的很想要一款特色鸡尾酒。他当时超级兴奋。我喜欢特色鸡尾酒。我知道。他也喜欢。我当时想，呃。但他想要，他喜欢莫斯科骡子，所以他想要莫斯科骡子，但他想用，是波旁威士忌吗？我可能要说错了。其实叫肯塔基骡子。他们做得有点不一样，但他希望每个人的伴手礼是一个铜马克杯。你还记得这个吗，詹娜？我喜欢我的铜马克杯。好吧。你把你的带回家了。对。我跟乔希说，乔希，大家不会意识到他们可以把杯子带回家。
They're not. And he's like, yes, they will. We'll say it's the party favor. They get to take a copper mug home engraved on it. It was like our wedding date. I was like, babe, this is really nice. People are not going to take them home. And we got into a little fight about it. It was planning the wedding. Guess what? What? We have 55 copper mugs. Oh, no. Well, Lee and I both took our mugs home. I knew that that was your wedding favor, probably because you told me. And also we had a sign. It had your table where you went to get seated, tied in a ribbon with your name. And they said this copper mug is yours to take home. Now, to be fair, Angela, if you had been a guest at your own wedding, would you have read the sign
他们不会的。他说，会的，他们会的。我们会说是派对伴手礼。他们可以把印有日期的铜马克杯带回家。上面印着我们的婚礼日期。我说，宝贝，这真的很好。大家不会把它们带回家的。为此我们还小吵了一架。那是筹备婚礼的时候。你猜怎么着？什么？我们有55个铜马克杯。哦，不。好吧，我和李都把杯子带回家了。我知道那是你们的婚礼伴手礼，可能是因为你告诉过我。而且我们还有一个指示牌。上面有你入座的桌子，用缎带系着你的名字。上面写着这个铜马克杯是你的，可以带回家。公平起见，安吉拉，如果你是你自己婚礼的宾客，你会看那个指示牌
and taken home your mug? Jenna, when it comes to getting free things, I read. Okay. That's it. You know what I wouldn't have read? The instructions on where to park. That's correct. I would have circled around until I figured it out. But I would have known to take the copper mug home. Fair enough. All right. Well, now we have some big news. Scrantinicity is going to be playing at Phyllis's reception. She hired Kevin's band Scrantinicity. It's their third gig. Their previous two gigs were for members of their own band. But before they begin playing their set, Kevin asked the crowd, has anyone seen Uncle Al? He has dementia and his family is really worried about him.
然后把你的杯子带回家吗？詹娜，说到白拿东西，我都会看。好吧。就这样。你知道我不会看什么吗？关于在哪停车的说明。没错。我会一直绕圈子，直到我想出来。但我会知道把铜马克杯带回家。好吧。好了，现在我们有个重大新闻。Scrantinicity乐队将会在菲莉丝的招待会上表演。她雇了凯文的乐队Scrantinicity。这是他们的第三场演出。他们前两场演出是为他们乐队自己的成员演出的。但在他们开始演奏之前，凯文问台下观众，有人看到阿尔叔叔吗？他有痴呆症，他的家人真的很担心他。
And then he immediately launches into Roxanne. The timing of that is so perfect. Well, Angela, we got a lot of questions about the band. Becky, Hadassah, Marie, Sam and Sarah all wanted to know, was it really Brian Baumgartner singing at the wedding and was he really playing the drums? Yes and yes. Yes and yes. And he practiced, you guys. He took it really seriously. He worked so hard on that and I thought he did such a great job. Yeah. Well, I have an observation, Jenna. Wasn't this also the band that was going to play at Pam's wedding? Yep. So put it on the list. Put it on the list and speaking of, Roy is about to find Pam and he tells her he is so impressed by all the details at this wedding and that Phyllis
然后他立刻唱起了《Roxanne》。这个时机真是太完美了。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于乐队的问题。贝姬、哈达莎、玛丽、萨姆和萨拉都想知道，婚礼上真的是布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳在唱歌吗，他真的在打鼓吗？是的，而且是的。是的，而且是的。而且他练习了，伙计们。他真的很认真。他为此付出了巨大的努力，我觉得他做得太棒了。好吧，我有一个观察，詹娜，这不是也准备在帕姆婚礼上表演的那个乐队吗？没错。所以把它记在清单上。记在清单上，说起来，罗伊正要去找帕姆，他告诉帕姆，他对这场婚礼的所有细节印象深刻，而且菲莉丝
has such great taste. Well, Jenna, there is a deleted scene. It's fantastic. Phyllis comes up to Pam at the reception and is like, Hey, you might have noticed that Bob and I use the same after dinner mints like party favor from your wedding that you had planned. I hope that's okay. And you're like, basically Pam's like, uh, just the mints. So wait, can you play it Sam? I recorded it. Are you enjoying yourself? Oh yeah, I'm having a great time. Good. You know, I don't know if you noticed but Bob and I borrowed your idea for the after dinner mints that you were going to have at your wedding. Oh yeah, that and also everything. I mean, the dress and the flowers and the fish and the cake. You know, we sound like you're keeping track. Oh, I just, you know, I could make
的品味真好。好吧，詹娜，有一个被删减的片段。太精彩了。菲莉丝在招待会上走到帕姆面前说，嘿，你可能注意到了，我和鲍勃用了你原计划在婚礼上用的那种饭后薄荷糖作为伴手礼。希望这没问题。然后你，基本上帕姆说，呃，只有薄荷糖？所以等等，萨姆你能放一下吗？我录下来了。你玩得开心吗？哦，很好，我玩得很开心。太好了。你知道，我不知道你有没有注意到，我和鲍勃借用了你的主意，就是你原本打算在婚礼上用的饭后薄荷糖。哦，对，还有所有东西。我是说，婚纱、鲜花、鱼还有蛋糕。听起来你一直在记着呢。哦，我只是，你知道，如果你们想要功劳的话，我可以
an announcement if what you want is credit. No, I, oh, maybe I should just move on. Oh, that is amazing. I mean, how passive aggressive is that? Would you like me to make an announcement so you can get credit? It's so amazing. Well, we asked Phyllis about this particular storyline and she actually had some thoughts on the matter. So Sam, play the clip. Pam said, you know, that I'd stole her everything about her wedding that I had stolen it and that I think the writers kind of like to like to write Phyllis kind of snarky sometimes. Well, when I got to thinking about it, I don't think that Phyllis Vance, Phyllis Lapin Vance, stole Pam's ideas and colors and flowers and stuff because she was being vindictive. I think that Phyllis had an admiration for Pam
宣布一下。不，我，哦，也许我该走开。哦，太惊艳了。我是说，这也太被动攻击了吧？你想让我宣布一下好让你邀功吗？太惊艳了。好吧，我们问过菲莉丝关于这个特定剧情的看法，她实际上对这件事有一些想法。所以萨姆，放一下音频。帕姆说，你知道的，我偷走了她关于婚礼的一切，我是说我偷走了那些，而且我觉得编剧们有时候挺喜欢把菲莉丝写得很尖酸刻薄的。嗯，当我开始思考的时候，我不认为菲莉丝·万斯，菲莉丝·拉平·万斯，偷了帕姆的主意、颜色、鲜花之类的东西是因为她怀恨在心。我觉得菲莉丝其实很崇拜帕姆
and I thought, if Pam likes those colors, then those must be pretty special. So if that was always kind of a back story in my mind that I wasn't being nasty, that I was being, you know, kind of honoring Pam's, Pam's wishes for her ill-fated wedding, but she ended up having a great wedding, didn't she? Aww. That is just Phyllis being Phyllis. Yeah. Phyllis Smith is so sweet. I do think Phyllis Lapin was a little, a little shady. Yes, I think so too. But it also kind of explains that snarky comment. You know, if that was where she was coming from of like, well, I was just, I admired your choices, but I guess if you need a bunch of credit, you know. Yeah. Well, I think it's sweet because it really speaks to how much Pam shared with Phyllis about her wedding planning.
我觉得，如果帕姆喜欢那些颜色，那一定非常特别。所以在我心里一直有一种背景故事，我不是故意的，我只是，你知道，某种程度上是在向帕姆致敬，尊重帕姆为她那场夭折的婚礼所做的心愿，但她最后还是办了一场很棒的婚礼，不是吗？噢。这只是菲莉丝的本色出演。对。菲莉丝·史密斯太温柔了。我确实觉得菲莉丝·拉平有点，有点阴险。是的，我也这么觉得。但这也某种程度上解释了那个尖酸的评论。你知道，如果她的出发点是，好吧，我只是很欣赏你的选择，但我想如果你需要一堆功劳的话，你知道的。好吧，我觉得很温柔，因为它真的很能说明帕姆和菲莉丝分享了多少关于她婚礼筹备的事。
And you see little snippets of that where Phyllis is showing an interest like they're in the kitchen and then Jim walks in. But this is the person that Pam could share with at work and was probably the only person who took an interest in her wedding. So I think that's why it was especially surprising to Pam where she was like, oh. Yeah. Oh yeah. Angela Martin didn't need to hear about your wedding. She probably judged you for doing work on it at work. She did. I think there's, you have a whole thing where you come down on me about it. I know. All right. So now it's time for the speeches, everyone. Bob's best man, Randy, finishes up his speech and Michael jumps up. He has an amazing line. He's got a 40 minute speech plan. Yeah. I'm gonna be your host for the next 40 minutes.
你能看到一些小片段，菲莉丝表现出兴趣，就像他们在厨房里，然后吉姆走进来。但这就是帕姆在工作时可以倾诉的人，而且可能是唯一一个对她的婚礼感兴趣的人。所以我认为这就是为什么这对帕姆来说特别吃惊，她当时想，哦。是啊。哦，是的。安吉拉·马丁才不需要听你的婚礼呢。她可能还在心里评判你在工作时间干私活呢。她确实会。我觉得，你有一整套说辞来数落我。我知道。好吧，现在是致辞时间了，各位。鲍勃的伴郎兰迪致辞结束，迈克尔跳了起来。他有一句绝妙的台词。他计划了一场40分钟的致辞。对。我要做你们接下来40分钟的主持人。
And it's all like on napkins. Well, a lot of people wanted to know how much of Michael's toast was improvised. Crystal, Sammy, Sarah, Aubrey and Regan all asked, also was it hard to keep a straight face? Well, almost all of that speech was scripted. And yes, it's always hard to keep a straight face. But Phyllis had a different take on this. Here's what she had to say. Anytime Michael opened his mouth, it was hard to keep a straight face. And at that point in the script, he was kind of hurtful, but he didn't even know it. So I didn't really have to, to strain to keep a straight face on, on that particular scene, because I was so hurt that he was saying all those crummy things about me. Some true, but some not. No, no. Yeah, I love that Phyllis is like, no, I was so in the moment
而且全写在餐巾纸上。好吧，很多人想知道迈克尔的祝酒词有多少是即兴的。水晶、萨米、萨拉、奥布里和雷根都问了，还有，保持面部严肃很难吗？好吧，几乎所有的致辞都是有剧本的。是的，保持面部严肃总是很难的。但菲莉丝对此有不同的看法。她是这么说的。只要迈克尔一开口，就很难保持面部严肃。而在剧本的那部分，他的话有点伤人，但他自己甚至都不知道。所以对于那场特定的戏，我其实不需要费劲去保持面部严肃，因为他说那些讨厌的话真的深深伤害了我。有些是真的，但有些不是。不，不。对，我很喜欢菲莉丝说，不，我当时完全沉浸在
playing being hurt. And this reminds me of her scene in the first Christmas episode, when Michael was so rude to her about her homemade oven mitt. And all the rest of us were just cracking up and Phyllis stayed in character. She was hurt. And she didn't break. No, she's a total pro. I mean, she really took all of her, all of the different moments of the script that she was in. She really, really played it honest. Well, I want to give a shout out here to Bob's best man. He was played by Brian Douglas Hatton. And he's been in a bunch of stuff, including a recurring role as a detective on Monk. Oh, it's another monk person. Another office monk crossover. There you go. Well, I have to point out something that's so ridiculous, but you know,
扮演受伤者的情绪中。这让我想起了她在第一集圣诞节里的那一幕，当时迈克尔对她自制的烤箱手套非常粗鲁。我们其他人都笑翻了，而菲莉丝依然保持着角色状态。她受伤了。而且她没有笑场。不，她是个十足的专业演员。我是说，她真的把剧本里属于她的所有不同时刻，都演得非常真诚。好吧，我要在这里感谢鲍勃的伴郎。他由布赖恩·道格拉斯·哈顿饰演。他演过很多作品，包括在《神探阿蒙》里扮演过一个常驻侦探角色。哦，又是一个《神探阿蒙》的人。另一个《办公室》和《神探阿蒙》的联动。就是这样。好吧，我得指出一件超级荒谬的事，但你知道，
it is my way. Michael continues his speech and says that their couple celebrity name would be FLOB. Yeah, I looked it up. I was like, when did people start doing this, like combining the names? And this is what the internet said, guys. The first time a celebrity couple's name was combined was Benifer. I was going to say Benifer. Yes. Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez. How does everyone know this? This is like a unanimous thought online that Benifer started it all. I knew it. There you go. The next one after Benifer was Brangelina. Yes, Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie. And then I guess there's one for Kanye West and Kim Kardashian. And it's Kim Yee. Oh yeah, Kim Yee. I've heard that. I haven't heard that. That one is not quite in my vernacular
这就是我的风格。迈克尔继续致辞，说他们两人的名人合称叫FLOB。对，我查了一下。当时我想，人们是从什么时候开始这么做的，把名字组合在一起？互联网上是这么说的，伙计们。名人情侣名字第一次被组合在一起是本妮弗。我刚想说本妮弗。对。本·阿弗莱克和詹妮弗·洛佩兹。怎么每个人都知道这个？网上一致认为本妮弗开创了先河。我早就知道了。就是这样。本妮弗之后下一个是布兰吉莉娜。对，布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉。然后我想坎耶·韦斯特和金·卡戴珊也有一个。叫金易。哦对，金易。我听说过。我没听过那个。那个不在我的常用词汇里
as much as Benifer and Brangelina. Well, but some people pointed out that, you know, Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston would have also been a Benifer. No, they would have been a Brenifer. Well, after he does their name mashup, he goes on to do what I think he thinks is like a fun, playful, kind of roast of Phyllis where he tells everyone that her nickname in high school was Easy Rider. Well, that's it for Bob. Bob's like, you're out of here, buddy. And he takes the microphone and he throws Michael out of the wedding. As Michael screams, I hate you. This is the second time he's screamed, I hate you at a wedding. This is full circle for him now. He's the little boy all over again, not getting to be part of the wedding. Groom's been out there. If Jenna and I
不像本妮弗和布兰吉莉娜那么熟。不过，有人指出，布拉德·皮特和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿其实也可以叫布妮弗。不，他们应该叫布雷尼弗。好吧，在他把他们的名字揉合在一起之后，他接着做了一件他自己觉得是既有趣、好玩又有点恶搞菲莉丝的事，他告诉大家菲莉丝在高中时的绰号是“逍遥骑士”。好吧，鲍勃受够了。鲍勃说，你给我滚蛋，老兄。他拿过麦克风，把迈克尔赶出了婚礼。迈克尔尖叫着喊道，我恨你。这是他第二次在婚礼上尖叫着喊我恨你。这对他来说算是一个轮回了。他又变成了那个小男孩，无法参与婚礼。新郎在外头。如果詹娜和我
can impart anything on you, don't roast the bride. Yeah, good one. It never goes well. No, it's her day. Yeah, let her have her day. Yeah, you can roast the groom. Don't roast the bride. All right, we've got a bunch of little moments and we talked with Ken about this. I this we kind of move into like the rest of the storytelling here in this episode is done in these like little vignettes. We have Jim kind of comes up to Pam and is like, why aren't you going to dance? And it's a little bit of a flirty moment. A little bit. He says, you look cute. It's a total flirt moment. Yeah. And Pam knows it's a flirt moment. So now she's like, Oh, but then, you know, he's off dancing with Karen. This is a series of moments where Jim and Pam both kind of get their hopes up and then
能传授你们什么经验的话，千万别恶搞新娘。对，说得好。从来没有好下场。不，这是她的日子。对，让她过好她的日子吧。对，你可以恶搞新郎。千万别恶搞新娘。好了，我们有很多小插曲，我们和肯聊过这个。我们，这集的故事接下来基本上就是通过这些小片段来推进的。我们看到吉姆走到帕姆身边说，你怎么不去跳舞？这是一个有点调情的时刻。有一点。他说，你看起来很可爱。这绝对是调情时刻。对。帕姆也知道这是调情时刻。所以现在她想，哦，但随后，你知道，他和凯伦一起去跳舞了。这是一连串的时刻，吉姆和帕姆两人的希望都被点燃，然后
gets their get their hopes dashed. Michael tries to sneak back in the wedding, but Dwight won't let him in. Dwight's so pleased. He's so pleased to be kicking him out. And then Pam is sort of sulking in a corner. And you hear you were meant for me by Jewel. And Roy comes up to Pam and is like, Oh, my gosh, they're playing our song. And she's like, Yeah, it's so weird. I thought they only played the police. And he's like, well, I gave him 20 bucks. Do you want to dance? Pam is very moved by this. It's thoughtful. It is thoughtful. And Roy is really making an effort. And they go when they dance together. And then the camera pans. And we see Angela and Dwight have sneaked off and they are dancing together. Yes. So you guys, this shot was really fun to do. We had to do it at night.
又破灭了。迈克尔试图溜回婚礼现场，但德怀特不让他进。德怀特太高兴了。他赶人赶得太高兴了。然后帕姆有点闷闷不乐地坐在角落里。你听到了朱尔斯的《You were meant for me》。罗伊走到帕姆身边说，哦天哪，他们在放我们的歌。帕姆说，是啊，太奇怪了。我以为他们只放警察乐队的歌。他说，噢，我给了他们20块钱。你想跳舞吗？帕姆对此非常感动。很贴心。确实很贴心。罗伊真的在努力。他们一起去跳舞了。然后镜头一转。我们看到安吉拉和德怀特偷偷溜走了，他们正在一起跳舞。对，所以伙计们，这个镜头拍起来非常有趣。我们必须在晚上拍。
So we did it one evening. It was outside. And Ken, when he had scouted the whole church, found this back door that then had steps that led down, right? And so we decided to film it there. Those steps actually faced the street, which was a busy street. And we didn't have it blocked off. No one was crossing the street. So it was just people going about their evening. And as we slow danced in one take, a car drove by with the windows down and they went, Oh my God, Dwight! Dwight! Angela! We had to do the takeover again. That's amazing. Oh my gosh, I love that. After this dance, Roy is like, Hey, do you want to get out of here? And Pam says, Yes. And they walk off and they're holding hands and Jim sees it in it just hits you like a ton of bricks when he watches her leave with him.
所以我们找了一个晚上拍。外面。肯在踩点整个教堂时，发现了这个后门，门外有通往下面的台阶，对吧？所以我们决定在那里拍摄。那些台阶其实正对著街道，那是一条很忙碌的街道。我们没有封锁街道。没有人过马路。所以只是人们在过他们的夜生活。正当我们一镜到底地跳着慢舞时，一辆车开过去，车窗开着，车里的人喊道，哦天哪，德怀特！德怀特！安吉拉！我们不得不重新拍这一镜。太棒了。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。跳完这支舞后，罗伊说，嘿，你想离开这儿吗？帕姆说，好。他们手拉着手走开，吉姆看到了这一幕，看着她跟他一起离开，那种感觉就像一块砖头狠狠砸在你心上。
And then he has a talking head where he's like, You know what? I'm glad I'm here with Karen. Yeah. Yeah. And then we have a few moments Karen singing with the band. Rashida mentioned this when she came on the podcast that she was so nervous to have to sing. She could not have been more adorable in this moment. When he says, I'm glad I'm with Karen. And then it cuts to her singing and dancing. She's the cutest person on the planet. She was so stinkin cute. Yes. And I think Rashida would be happy to know that Ariana November wrote in to say, Is Rashida Jones a trained singer because she is really good. And I thought she had a great voice too. I did too. I did too. And then I even thought, you know, Jim's reaction, like waving his phone in the air.
然后他有一个单人访谈镜头，他说，你知道吗？我很高兴能和凯伦在一起。对。对。然后我们有一些凯伦和乐队一起唱歌的片段。拉什达在播客里提到过，她要唱歌时紧张得要命。她在这一幕里简直可爱到爆。当他说，我很高兴能和凯伦在一起。然后镜头切到她边唱边跳。她是地球上最可爱的人。她太可爱了。是的。而且我想拉什达会很高兴听到阿里安娜·诺维博来信说，拉什达·琼斯是受过专业训练的歌手吗，因为她唱得真的很好。我觉得她嗓音也很棒。我也这么觉得。我也这么觉得。然后我甚至觉得，你知道，吉姆的反应，像是在空中挥舞着手机。
It was cute. Yeah. So then Phyllis tosses her bouquet and Ryan swats it away from Kelly. Kelly was clearly going to catch that bouquet and Ryan swats it away. A lot of people wanted to know if that was a scripted moment. Yes. Yes, it was. Yeah. Ryan can't let Kelly catch that. Do you know what that would do for their relationship? No, no, no. But who does catch it? Toby's date. And I loved so much, Jenna, that one-on-one of Toby to camera where he's like, Toby, yeah. Yeah. Well, now we move outside and Michael is sitting on a bench with Uncle Al. Yeah. And they're having this big heart to heart. How perfect is that? Oh, it was such a great scene. We had some people write in Christie Carroll, Connor Yakes and Ashley Howell all asked,
很可爱。对。然后菲莉丝扔捧花，瑞恩一把从凯利手里拍开。凯利本来显然要接住捧花的，被瑞恩给拍开了。很多人想知道这拍的是不是剧本安排。对。是的，是安排好的。对。瑞恩可不能让凯利接住那个。你知道那对他们的关系意味着什么吗？不，不，不。但谁接住了？托比的女伴。詹娜，我太喜欢托比对着镜头的那个独白了，他说，托比，耶。对。好吧，现在我们来到户外，迈克尔和阿尔叔叔正坐在一张长椅上。对。他们在推心置腹地交谈。多完美啊？哦，这真是一场精彩的戏。有些观众来信，克里斯蒂·卡罗尔、康纳·亚克斯和阿什莉·霍尔都问，
can you talk about the actors that played Uncle Al and Phyllis's dad, Albert, because they were both fabulous? Well, guys, George Ives played Uncle Al and he was a longtime television actor. He appeared in Mr. Ed, The Andy Griffith Show, My Three Sons, Bewitched and a bunch of movies. He passed away in 2013 and the office was his last television show that he appeared in according to IMDB. Yeah. And he was just absolutely fabulous. Yeah. And then Hansford Rowe played Phyllis's father. He passed away in 2017. He was a very accomplished actor. Listen to the movies he's been in. He was in Dante's Peak, Baby Boom, Three Days of the Condor. He's been in a ton of television shows, Modern Family, Will and Grace, Curb Your Enthusiasm,
能聊聊扮演阿尔叔叔和菲莉丝父亲阿尔伯特的演员吗，因为他们都太棒了？好吧，伙计们，乔治·艾夫斯饰演阿尔叔叔，他是一位资深电视演员。他出演过《爱德先生》、《安迪·格里菲斯秀》、《我的三个儿子》、《家有仙妻》和一堆电影。他在2013年去世，《办公室》是根据IMDB记载他出演的最后一部电视剧。对。他绝对太棒了。对。然后汉斯福德·罗饰演菲莉丝的父亲。他在2017年去世。他是一位非常出色的演员。听听他演过哪些电影。他演过《但丁峰》、《婴儿潮》、《秃鹰的三日》。他演过成吨的电视剧，有《摩登家庭》、《威尔与格蕾丝》、《抑制热情》、
Six Feet Under. But here's the one that got me. He was in this mini series called V. Do you remember V? Was it about aliens taking over? Yes. And then you went- It was from the 80s. Yeah. People would do the sign, the V, the little sign with their fingers. Yes. Yeah. And the way you found out they were aliens is they would peel off their skin and they were like lizard people underneath. Yeah. Oh my God. I forgot about that show. Remember how shocking it was when you saw their lizard skin? Yeah. Well, listen, we had a fan question from Sierra, Katie Regan, Katie Slemp, Allison and Lexi. They all noticed that at 19 minutes 30 seconds as Phyllis is leaving the church, she seems to have a black brace on her right knee. Well, guys, I asked Phyllis about this
《六尺之下》。但下面这个震惊到我了。他演过一部叫《V字特工队》的迷你剧。你还记得《V》吗？讲的是外星人入侵吗？对。然后你- 是80年代的。对。人们会做那个手势，V字，用手指做出小手势。对。对。你发现他们是外星人的方式是他们会剥掉皮肤，下面其实是蜥蜴人。对。天哪。我都忘了那部剧了。还记得看到他们的蜥蜴皮肤时有多震惊吗？对。好吧，听着，我们有一个来自西埃拉、凯蒂·雷根、凯蒂·斯莱姆普、艾莉森和莱克西的粉丝提问。他们都注意到在19分30秒时，菲莉丝离开教堂时，右膝上似乎戴着黑色的护膝。好吧，伙计们，我问过菲莉丝这件事，
and she does not remember. She was definitely not injured during the making of this episode. But, you know, she said she went through a few injuries during her time on the show. And I guess this must have been when she was favoring that knee a little bit. But I stopped it and sure enough, there is a little bit of a bandage there. I did not catch that. But yeah. Oh man, we have really good background catchers that watch the show. We do. Well, now we have this tag, this little scene at the end and it's Bob and Phyllis. They're doing that thing where you shove the wedding cake in the face kind of thing. And of course, Michael wants to get in on it. It's really awkward. I don't know if you noticed on this cake. It was so amazing.
她不记得了。在拍这集的时候她绝对没有受伤。但是，你知道，她说她在剧组期间经历过几次受伤。我想这一定是在她那段时间稍微有点偏爱那个膝盖的时候。但我暂停下来一看，果然，那里确实有一小块绷带。我没注意到这个。不过，天哪。哦，天哪，我们有非常厉害的细节控观众在看剧。确实。好吧，现在我们有了这个尾声，也就是结尾的一小段戏，是鲍勃和菲莉丝。他们在玩那种把婚礼蛋糕往对方脸里抹的把戏。当然，迈克尔也想插一脚。场面真的很尴尬。我不知道你们有没有注意到这个蛋糕。太惊艳了。
It was so well done. There was a full silver refrigerator made of fondant that sat on top of the cake as like the topper next to the little bride and groom figurine. I did not notice that. Yes. That is brilliant. Of course. Of course. There was a Vance refrigerator on the top of the cake with them. That was also cake. So, you know how you take the top part of the cake and you save it and you have it on your one-year anniversary? Yeah. They're going to eat that refrigerator their one-year anniversary. Did you do that? Did you save the top of your cake and eat it a year later? No. Did you? Oh, no. Did you? You know what? It's weird. I can't remember, but this past year, we just celebrated our 10th wedding anniversary. Lee and I, 10 years this
做得太精致了。蛋糕顶部除了有小新郎新娘雕像之外，还有一个用翻糖做的完整银色冰箱作为蛋糕装饰。我没注意到这个。是的。太绝了。当然。当然。蛋糕顶上有个万斯冰箱陪着他们。那也是蛋糕。所以，你知道大家都会把蛋糕顶部留下来保存，到一周年纪念日再吃吗？对。他们要在一周年纪念日吃那个冰箱。你这么做了吗？你保存了蛋糕顶部，一年后吃了吗？没有。你呢？哦，没有。你呢？你知道吗？很奇怪。我不记得了，但去年，我们刚庆祝了结婚10周年。我和李，今年10周年了。
year. That's amazing, lady. Well, and it happened during a pandemic and we had these plans that for our 10th wedding anniversary, we wanted to take a big trip and take the kids to the spot where Lee proposed to me and I wanted to have a family portrait taken in this spot. And that was, I mean, I've been had this in my head for like years since our 7th wedding anniversary. Yes. That this would be such a fun way to mark our 10th wedding anniversary. Well, you know, then we couldn't really go anywhere because our anniversary is in July. So, we ended up having dinner outside underneath our fruit trees and our original wedding planner, Beth Helmstetter, you know her, she set it all up for us. She came over, she wore a mask, she set this little table
太棒了，女士。而且这件事正好发生在疫情期间，我们原本计划在10周年纪念日时来一次大旅行，带着孩子们去李向我求婚的那个地方，我还想在那拍一张全家福。这就是，我是说，我脑子里一直盘算着这事，从我们7周年纪念日开始。是的。觉得这是纪念结婚10周年的好方式。好吧，你知道的，后来我们哪儿也不能去，因为我们的纪念日是七月。所以，我们最后在果树底下的户外吃晚饭，我们的婚礼策划师贝丝·赫尔姆斯泰特，你们认识她，她为我们安排好了一切。她过来了，戴着口罩，在树下摆了一张小桌子。
out under our trees. And do you know what she did for us? What? She had the records from our wedding and she had a tiny replica of our wedding cake made for us for four people so that our kids could eat our wedding cake on our 10th wedding anniversary. That is so special. That is so sweet. I wanted to tell you though, we didn't eat the top of our cake. That wasn't the type of cake we had at our wedding, but I have to tell you our topper story, which is, you know, we're a blended family. We were two whole families coming together. So, our children were a really big part of our wedding. They all wanted to speak at the ceremony. And then when it came time for the cake, instead of getting a traditional bride and groom figurine, we let the kids design this out of Legos. Oh, that's right.
你知道她为我们做了什么吗？什么？她保留了我们婚礼的档案记录，并为我们定制了一个四人份的婚礼蛋糕微型复制品，这样我们的孩子们就能在我们结婚10周年的时候吃上我们的婚礼蛋糕了。太特别了。太温馨了。不过我想告诉你，我们没有吃蛋糕的顶部。那不是我们婚礼上的蛋糕类型，但我得告诉你我们的蛋糕顶装饰的故事，你知道的，我们是重组家庭。我们是两个完整的家庭结合在一起。所以，我们的孩子们是我们婚礼非常重要的一部分。他们都想在仪式上发言。然后到了切蛋糕的时候，我们没有用传统的婚礼新郎新娘雕像，而是让孩子们用乐高积木自己设计了一个。哦，对哦。
And so we had a little Lego sort of like, they made like a little archway out of Legos. And then they put little Lego flowers on the white archway. And then they made Legos of me and Josh and then of each of them. So all three kids. So we had five little Legos under a Lego archway on top of our wedding cake. So sweet. So cute, right? And we saved it. It's on our mantle. Well, Lady, I just love all that. So we did get some questions about this cake scene. And guys, I want to let you know, so this was originally shot to be earlier in the episode. And then they just liked it. So they used it as the tag, but it was meant to go right before Dwight confronts Uncle Al for stealing the bread at the buffet and throws them out. Okay. There were some questions about why this was at
所以我们有一个用乐高做的小拱门。他们在白色拱门上放了乐高小花。然后他们用乐高拼出了我和乔希，还有他们三个人的乐高人偶。所以我们在婚礼蛋糕顶部的乐高拱门下有五个乐高小人。太温馨了。太可爱了，对吧？我们把它保存下来了。放在我们的壁炉架上。好吧，女士，我太喜欢这些了。所以我们确实收到了一些关于这个蛋糕场景的问题。伙计们，我想告诉你们，这个片段原本是拍摄放在这一集更前面的部分的。后来他们很喜欢。所以他们把它当成了尾声，但它本来应该紧挨着德怀特在自助餐区质问并赶走偷面包的阿尔叔叔之前。好吧。有人问为什么这个片段会出现在
the end of the episode. It was just sometimes we do that. Sometimes, you know, we cut back to a moment that might have happened earlier as our tag. Well, that's the fun thing about a cold open in a tag. Sometimes they don't have to be in sort of a time ordered manner. Yes. Yes. Well, the original tag of this episode was supposed to be a series of photos where Michael is photo bombing every single picture. I remember taking these pictures and you can find some of them. You can. Where are they? Office tally, maybe? Yeah. So for a while, NBC had these photos up on their website. And I don't think they're there anymore, but I'm going to do a little digging. And if we can find them, we'll put them up on the pod. But I remember shooting them. It was very, very fun. Yeah. I
这一集的结尾。有时候我们就会这么做。有时候，你知道，我们会把一个可能发生在更早时刻的片段剪辑回来作为尾声。好吧，片头和尾声有趣的地方就在于此。有时候它们不需要按照时间顺序排列。对。对。好吧，这集原本的尾声应该是一系列照片，迈克尔在每一张照片里都疯狂抢镜。我记得拍过这些照片，你们还能找到其中的一些。可以的。在哪儿呢？《办公室》记分板之类的？对。所以有一段时间，NBC把这些照片放在他们的官网上。我觉得现在不在那儿了，但我会去扒一扒。如果我们能找到，我们会把它放到播客上。但我记得拍过。非常非常有趣。对。我
remember those two. Well, you know, Jenna, we asked Phyllis about the cake and just about this episode, things she remembered and things that stood out to her. And here's what she had to say. Yes, it was very good cake. And we didn't really do that many takes of it. It was the end of the night. They didn't want to mess my face and hair up every time. So I think we just practiced it without messing it all over our faces. And then we did it just the one time. So no, we didn't, we didn't do that multiple times where it had to be cleaned up and this and that. And then Michael went crazy, of course, smearing it all over his face. And, you know, one of the funniest scenes that I think in the, that tore me up when I saw it for the first time was when Michael was outside
也记得那两个。好吧，你知道的，詹娜，我们问过菲莉丝关于蛋糕以及这一集的事，她还记得哪些事，有哪些事让她印象深刻。她是这么说的。对，蛋糕很好吃。我们其实没拍多少条。那是深夜了。他们不想每次都把我的脸和头发弄乱。所以我想我们只是排练了一下，没有把蛋糕弄得满脸都是。然后我们只实拍了一次。所以没有，我们没有拍好多次去清理来清理去。然后迈克尔当然就疯狂了，把蛋糕抹满全脸。你知道，我觉得在这一集里最搞笑的场景之一，当我第一次看到时笑得前仰后合的，就是迈克尔在外面
jumping at the window trying to look in after he'd been escorted out by Dwight. I don't know, for some reason, that just really tore me up. I thought that whole wedding was, was, of course I would, was a remarkable episode. Everybody had their, their shining moments in it. Kelly dressed in white and the whole Pam and Jim, Karen, Roy, Triangle, that was all great. It was just pretty special. And Ken, I think Ken directed that. He was fantastic. I always enjoyed working with him. And we were so blessed on that show. We had so many great writers, directors, and the fact that we all got to grow up together on the show, basically. Not just this episode, the whole nine seasons. And it was really a blessing then and continues to be to this day.
对着窗户又蹦又跳，试图往里看，在他被德怀特护送出去之后。我不知道，不知为什么，那一幕真的把我逗乐了。我觉得整个婚礼都是，当然，是一集相当了不起的剧集。每个人都在里面展现了高光时刻。凯利穿白色衣服，还有帕姆、吉姆、凯伦、罗伊的三角恋，都很棒。真的很特别。肯，我觉得是肯导演的。他太棒了。我一直很喜欢跟他合作。我们在这部剧里真的太有福气了。我们有那么多伟大的编剧、导演，而且我们大家基本上是一起在这部剧里长大的。不仅仅是这一集，整整九季。这在当时是种福气，直到今天依然如此。
I'm glad you enjoyed the episode. I'm assuming you did. And I'll talk to you later. Well, now we're wrapping up the episode. But Jenna, before we say goodbye, I have to talk about a few deleted scenes. One I talked about with Ken Whittingham about Angela's whole runner with Dennis. Yes. Dennis, the veterinarian, who she says, I'm sorry, but I'm with someone. She does end up turning Dennis down. But here are the two other deleted scenes that were so funny to me. Number one, Kevin has a talking head. He says that he has proposed to four different girls. Oh my gosh. Four. But Stacey was the first one to say yes. And you know, if it couldn't be Melissa Riley, then he's glad it was Stacey. Wow. Who the heck is Melissa Riley?
很高兴你喜欢这一集。我假设你是喜欢得。我们回头聊。好吧，现在我们要结束这一集了。但詹娜，在我们说再见之前，我得聊聊几个被删减的片段。其中一个我和肯·惠廷厄姆聊过，关于安吉拉和丹尼斯的那条线。对。丹尼斯，那个兽医，安吉拉对他说，对不起，但我有伴了。她最后确实拒绝了丹尼斯。但另外两个被删减的片段我觉得超级搞笑。第一，凯文有一段单人访谈。他说他向四个不同的女孩求过婚。天哪。四个。但斯黛西是第一个说“我愿意”的人。你知道，如果不是梅丽莎·莱利的话，他很高兴是斯黛西。哇。到底谁是梅丽莎·莱利？
I don't know. Okay. I thought that was delicious. And this is the other one. I loved Wedding Planners Listen Up. There is a deleted scene where Meredith holds up a party favor and it's a little tiny refrigerator magnet. And when you open the door to the refrigerator, there's a picture of Phyllis and Bob. Wow. Yeah. Well, she didn't steal that from Pam's wedding. She didn't steal that one. But don't you wish you had that magnet, that little refrigerator magnet? So in the deleted scene, we see this item. Yes. I took a screen grab of it. So who has that now? I don't know. But Meredith is the one who holds it up. She's like, did you guys get your little magnet? And it's a refrigerator. It's so cute. Angela, I love this refrigerator magnet that goes on your refrigerator so much
我不知道。好吧。我觉得这段太逗了。还有这个。婚礼策划师注意啦。有一个被删减的片段，梅丽莎举起一个伴手礼，是一个小小的冰箱贴，当你打开冰箱门时，里面有一张菲莉丝和鲍勃的照片。哇。对。好吧，她这个可不是从帕姆婚礼上偷的。这个她没偷。但难道你不想拥有那个磁铁，那个小冰箱贴吗？所以在这个被删减的片段里，我们看到了这个物品。对。我截屏了。那现在谁有这个？我不知道。但梅丽莎是把它举起来的人。她说，你们拿到小磁铁了吗？是个冰箱。太可爱了。安吉拉，我太喜欢这个可以贴在冰箱上的冰箱贴了，
that I would like you please because you're in charge of our merch. I am. I love it, you guys. If you ever have ideas, let me know. Well, I have one. So I'm letting you know. Will you please make a refrigerator magnet with a little door that opens and inside the refrigerator is me and you. I don't know why we're in the refrigerator. I just want to be in there. Okay. Okay. I can be holding a little jar of sourdough starter and you can be holding something too. A glass of wine. Sure. You open up the refrigerator to us, but you can put your own photo in there. Or we can just be on your refrigerator. We'd be happy to be there to keep you company. Sure. Well, you guys, that was Phyllis's wedding. A huge thank you to Phyllis Smith for sending in those audio files. And
以至于我想请你，因为你是负责我们的周边产品的。我是。我太喜欢了，伙计们。你们如果有什么好点子，随时告诉我。好吧，我有一个。所以我现在告诉你。你能做一个冰箱贴吗，带一个小门可以打开，冰箱里面是你和我。我不知道为什么我们在冰箱里。我就是想呆在里面。好吧。好吧。我可以拿着一小罐酸种面团，你也可以拿点别的。一杯酒。当然。你打开冰箱看到我们，但你也可以把自己照片放进去。或者我们直接呆在你的冰箱上。我们很乐意呆在那儿陪伴你。当然。好吧，伙计们，那就是菲莉丝的婚礼。非常感谢菲莉丝·史密斯发来这些音频文件。还有
of course. Oh my gosh. Thank you, Ken Whittingham. Yes, guys. We love you. We'll see you next week. Yeah. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当然。哦天哪。谢谢肯·惠廷厄姆。是的，伙计们。我们爱你们。我们下周见。Yeah. 再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwool、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。